Okay, here we go. This is going to be a smart list episode. Let's tune up the ears, get the wax out. What are you doing? The papers are getting set. The prep is done. Okay, ready? Here we go. You guys ready to talk? Guys, guys, guys, guys.
好吧，我们开始吧。这一集我们要聊的是智囊清单。大家把耳朵竖起来，把耳垢清理干净。你在干嘛？文件都准备好了。前期工作也做完了。好了，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。你们准备好聊天了吗？伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，伙计们。
What? It's an all-new smart list. Oh, God. Smart list. Okay. Hey, guys, look. Wait, check this out. Oh, sure. Yeah. Yeah. Start right away.
什么？这是一个全新的智囊清单。哦，天哪。智囊清单。好吧。嘿，伙计们，看。等等，看看这个。哦，当然。太棒了。太棒了。马上开始。
Yeah. Have you been preparing, Sean? You see that? Look at the sign. Construction? No, that sign where my finger is. Chicago Theater. Wow, wow, wow. Did you know that a week ago that you were going to be staying in that apartment?
太棒了。肖恩，你一直在做准备吗？你看到了吗？看那个标志。施工中？不是，看我手指着的那个标志。芝加哥剧院。哇，哇，哇。你一周前就知道你要住在那个公寓里吗？
I knew, I knew the name of it, but I didn't know where it was. Yeah, Sean, for the listener, Sean started his stay there. What is it going to be like a multi-month stay in Chicago, right? Yeah, like three months, yeah. The first night he was there was Valentine's, and appropriately, he and Scotty saw a couple consummating Valentine's. A right cross street. And like in kind of like, it wasn't even like, all the lights were on,
我知道，我知道它的名字，但我不知道它在哪里。是的，肖恩，对于听众朋友们来说，肖恩开始在那里居住了。那将是一次在芝加哥长达数月的居住，对吧？对，大概三个月，对。他在那里的第一晚是情人节，很应景的是，他和斯科蒂看到了一对情侣在庆祝情人节。就在正对面的街上。而且就像那种，甚至都不是，所有的灯都亮着，
it was somewhat impromptu. We won't get into the graphic details of it, but it was clearly not a planned consummation. No, all parties were upright is the point. It was half a wobbly H, okay? Isn't that wild? And Scotty's like, I go, what are you looking at? And he's like, come over to this window.
这有点即兴。我们就不去探讨那些生动的细节了，但显然这不是一个有计划的亲热。没有，重点是所有当事人都还是直立的。那真是一半摇摇晃晃的H，好吧？是不是很疯狂？然后斯科蒂说，我问，你在看什么？然后他说，快到这个窗户来。
How long was he looking out the window before you noticed he was there? Quite a while. It was a minute. And he kept saying, come look at these people in love. Right? He kept saying, look at these people in love. Sean, this is love. In case you didn't know, it's Valentine's Day.
在你注意到他在那儿之前，他看了多久的窗外？挺长时间的。有一分钟。他一直说，快来看这些相爱的人。对吧？他一直说，看这些相爱的人。肖恩，这就是爱。如果你不知道的话，今天是情人节。
Okay, this is what love is. Okay? Now, do you think they wanted to be seen? That's why the shades were up? Yeah. No, I think people are just used to living. Well, Will, you can speak to this. You've lived in New York City.
好了，这就是爱。好吗？现在，你觉得他们想被人看到吗？这就是为什么百叶窗没拉上？对。不，我觉得人们只是习惯了生活。好吧，威尔，你可以谈谈这个。你在纽约市住过。
Do you just get used to the fact that people might be watching you? Or do you, well, that? I think you go back and forth. I think that you have moments where you're like, oh my God. And then you also have moments where you're like, you just live your life and you don't think about it. You can't think about it all the time. I mean, you could pull the shades down.
你是不是已经习惯了别人可能会看着你？或者说，好吧，这个？我觉得你心态会摇摆不定。我觉得有时候你会觉得，哦，天哪。然后有时候你也会觉得，你只是在过自己的生活，根本不会去想这个。你不可能无时无刻都在想这个。我是说，你可以把百叶窗拉下来。
Sure. I would suggest that those people who are engaged in that, in that moment, didn't care. And in fact, that that probably was there to heighten their experience. Now, Shawnee, you're back out on the road. Yeah. We'll get to our guests here, apologies. But Shawnee, how's the first few days of rehearsal going?
当然。我猜那些正在经历那一刻的人根本不在乎。事实上，那可能还增强了他们的体验。好了，肖尼，你又开始巡演了。对。我们马上聊我们的嘉宾，抱歉。不过，肖尼，前几天的排练进行得怎么样？
Oscar Levant. How's Oscar Levant? Good. So, Shawn's doing, it's not a musical, right? It's got some music in it, but it's a play. No, it's a play. It's a play. Okay.
奥斯卡·黎凡特。奥斯卡·黎凡特怎么样？不错。所以，肖恩在做，这不是音乐剧，对吧？里面有一些音乐，但这是一部话剧。不，这是一部话剧。这是一部话剧。好吧。
So, he's there now. He's a weekend of rehearsals and it's pretty arduous to rehearse a play for the listener. And, Shawn, are you loving it or having regrets? Oh, my God. I love it so much. I mean, it's a ton of work, but thank you for asking. It's, yeah, it's a ton of work, but really rewarding.
所以，他现在在那儿。他排练了一周末，对于听众来说，排练一部话剧相当辛苦。而且，肖恩，你是在享受其中还是感到后悔？哦，天哪。我太喜欢了。我是说，有大量的工作要做，但谢谢你问我。是的，有大量的工作，但真的很有收获。
You know what I love the most is the, we're in the process of sitting around talking about the play page by page, making sure everything makes sense. And the backstory informs what the characters are doing. It's kind of, Is it the first time the play is being done? Yeah. It's a brand new play by Doug Wright, who won the Pulitzer for I Am My Own Wife. And he wrote the movie Quills and Amazing Writer.
你知道我最喜欢的是什么吗，我们正在坐在一起逐页讨论剧本，确保一切都讲得通。而且背景故事为角色的行为提供了依据。这有点像是，这是这部剧第一次被搬上舞台吗？对。这是道格·赖特创作的一部全新话剧，他曾凭《我自己的妻子》获得普利策奖。他还写过电影《鹅毛笔》，是个了不起的作家。
Well, let's plug Doug for sure. Yeah. You know. Does he have a website? Oh, by the way, it's called Good Night Oscar. It's called Good Night Oscar. Oh, God. And we have told every audience across the country knows Oscar Levant backstage
好吧，我们一定要为道格宣传一下。对。你知道的。他有网站吗？哦，顺便说一句，它叫《晚安，奥斯卡》。它叫《晚安，奥斯卡》。哦，天哪。我们已经告诉过全国各地的每一位观众，每个人都知道奥斯卡·黎凡特在后台
at the Tonight Show. Nobody's going to go to the play now. Everybody feels like they've already seen it. Well, maybe they'll check out Murderville again. Yeah, exactly. Let's give that another play. That's not a bad idea. That's not a bad idea.
《今夜秀》的后台。现在没人会去看话剧了。大家都觉得自己已经看过了。好吧，也许他们会再去看看《谋杀ville》。对，没错。再重播一次那个吧。这主意不错。这主意不错。
How's that doing? It's going to really be enjoying it. It's been very nice to see people enjoy it and have fun with it. Listener, that's a show on Netflix called Murderville that Will Arnett brought to all of us. It's a very good show. And, you know, well, so we'll go from that. So from Good Night Oscar to Murderville to the other big question
那个进展如何？大家真的很喜欢它。看到大家喜欢它并从中获得乐趣，感觉非常好。听众朋友们，那是Netflix上的一档节目，叫《谋杀ville》，是威尔·阿奈特带给我们的。这是一档非常棒的节目。然后，好吧，所以我们要从那个说起。从《晚安，奥斯卡》到《谋杀ville》再到另一个重大问题
we got a lot on the tour. Is Jason, when are the final six episodes of I Am My Own Wife? I'm back. It's seven, but not a big deal. Seven. I don't know. I wanted to surprise people with the seventh. Sorry.
我们在巡演中收到了很多关于贾森的问题，最后六集的《我自己的妻子》什么时候播？我回来了。是七集，不过也没大不了的。七集。我不知道。我想用第七集给人们一个惊喜。抱歉。
There's a bonus. After the credits, there's one more. They're going to announce that soon. So you can't say. I cannot say, but it will be soon. All right. Here comes our guest, y'all. OK.
还有彩蛋。演职员表放完后，还有一个。他们很快就会宣布了。所以你不能说。我不能说，但很快就会有了。好了。我们的嘉宾来啦，各位。好吧。
All right. Sean, well, today I get into a little bit of trouble with you guys. I apologize. I know that you hate it when I bring an academic on or a scientist, big brains in general. But this guy seems to really just hold on. He seems to really be liked by those who have taken his class. And teaching filmmaking for almost 30 years now,
好吧。肖恩，今天我要和你们惹点小麻烦了。我很抱歉。我知道当我和学者或科学家，总而言之就是高智商人士交流时，你们就很讨厌。但这家伙似乎真的，等一下。他似乎真的很受那些上过他课的学生的喜爱。而且他教授电影制作已经快30年了，
and out of some of the top institutions in town, he's taught his students mostly through doing in that he's managed to gather the funds necessary to himself make nine films on subjects as odd as a single digit, nighttime mucus, party drinks, hemophilia, major golf tournament, addiction, haunted textiles, and Italian candy. And if you can believe it, these films have yielded an 11 Academy Award nominations.
他从城里的一些顶尖学府毕业，他主要是通过实践来教导学生的，他自己设法筹集了制作九部电影所需的资金，这些电影的主题千奇百怪，比如个位数、夜间粘液、派对饮料、血友病、高尔夫锦标赛、成瘾、闹鬼纺织品和意大利糖果。如果你敢相信的话，这些电影获得了11项奥斯卡奖提名。
Most importantly, though, he's got four kids, a house in the valley, and married to the coolest woman we three know. Gang, it's Paul Thomas Anderson. No. Yes. Oh, my gosh. Hello. Oh, my gosh.
不过最重要的是，他有四个孩子，在山谷区有一栋房子，还娶了我们三个认识的最酷的女人。伙计们，他是保罗·托马斯·安德森。不。是的。哦，天哪。你好。哦，天哪。
Hi, guys. It's so good to see you. Did you guys have a guest with that list of subject matters? You really had me reeling on that. Did I bury it good? That's a great intro. I worked on that for a full nine minutes this morning. Paul, would you have been able to guess yourself with that intro?
嗨，伙计们。很高兴见到你们。听了那一长串主题，你们觉得会有嘉宾吗？你刚才真的把我搞糊涂了。我藏得好吗？这是一个很棒的开场白。我今天早上为此花了整整九分钟。保罗，听了那个开场白，你能猜出是你自己吗？
Come on. Now let's guess it. So a single digit, which one is that, man? I did it in order. A single digit obviously is hard eight. Hard eight, yeah. Nighttime mucus? Nighttime mucus.
来吧。现在我们来猜猜。那么个位数，那是哪一部，老兄？我是按顺序来的。个位数显然是《硬八点》。《硬八点》，对。夜间粘液？夜间粘液。
Come on. Boogie Nights, y'all. Party drinks. Oh, my God. OK. Party drinks. We've got punch, drunk love, hemophilia, there will be blood, golf tournament, obviously the master.
来吧。狂热之城，各位。派对饮料。哦，天哪。好吧。派对饮料。我们有《微醉的爱情》，血友病是《血色将至》，高尔夫锦标赛，显然是《大师》。
Addiction is inherent vice, haunted textiles, we'd know and love Phantom Thread, and Italian candy out in theaters now, the Valley Famous Licorice Pizza record store. Wow. That's incredible. All right. Pretty good.
成瘾是《性本恶》，闹鬼纺织品，我们知道并热爱的《魅影缝匠》，而意大利糖果现在正在影院上映，山谷里著名的《甘草比萨》唱片店。哇。太不可思议了。好吧。相当不错。
I'm so proud of myself, Paul. You can see I'm just beaming. Guys, we can't do early morning records. I'm still up for last night. This ain't today crossword version. Oh, man. Wait, but Oscar Levant is one of my heroes. Really?
保罗，我为自己感到骄傲。你可以看出我满面春风。伙计们，我们不能一大早就录音。我昨晚还没睡够呢。这可不是今天的填字游戏版本。哦，天哪。等等，但是奥斯卡·黎凡特是我的偶像之一。真的吗？
Oh, really? Oh, you go. You two, you two. He's amazing, isn't he? Yes. You know, there's a great Oscar Levant show that he did that was here on KTLA Channel 5, and Fred Astaire was one of the... That's exactly right.
哦，真的吗？哦，你走吧。你们两个，你们两个。他太棒了，对吧？是的。你知道，奥斯卡·黎凡特做过一个很棒的节目，就在这里的KTLA 5台播出，弗雷德·阿泰尔是其中一个……完全正确。
It was impossible to find forever and ever and ever. I have the whole thing if you want it. No, well, I remember it was this impossible to find thing, and then when this thing YouTube came around, I remember thinking, I'll see if this thing can really find something I want, and I put in the Oscar Levant show, and there it was. I said, oh, my God, I like YouTube.
那个节目以前怎么也找不到。如果你想要的话，我这里有完整版。不，好吧，我记得这是一个根本找不到的东西，然后当YouTube这个东西出现的时候，我记得我在想，我看看这东西能不能真的找到我想要的东西，我输入了“奥斯卡·黎凡特秀”，它就在那里。我说，哦，天哪，我喜欢YouTube。
It was there. They're great. Yeah, yeah. Dear Mr. YouTube, great job. What's your... While I'm thinking of it, because my brain doesn't hold stuff well, the first shot in Magnolia was that when you go through
它就在那里。它们太棒了。对，对。亲爱的YouTube先生，干得好。顺便问一下……因为我的脑子记不住东西，《木兰花》里的第一个镜头是当你穿过
the hallways and you go onto the soundstage, isn't that the Tonight Show stage? Yes. Yes, right? Yeah. Speaking of the Tonight Show, Oscar Levant, all that stuff. Yeah. What do they call it officially?
走廊然后走到演播室舞台上，那不是《今夜秀》的舞台吗？是的。是的，对吧？是的。说到《今夜秀》，奥斯卡·黎凡特，所有这些。是的。他们官方叫它什么？
It's NBC. It's where the Tonight Show with Johnny Carson, you know, they did that, but they also did the local news there. They had... Yeah. You know, I remember a big deal was that we were shooting, and we had to...
那是NBC。那是约翰尼·卡森的《今夜秀》录制的地方，你知道的，他们在那儿录节目，但他们也在那儿录制地方新闻。他们有……对。你知道，我记得当时一件大事是我们要拍戏，然后我们必须……
We had... It was the days of Paul Moyer. Do you remember Paul Moyer? Yeah. And we just needed to move his space over, you know, a couple of spots. And it was like, you know, three days of negotiations to move Paul Moyer's spot.
我们必须……那是保罗·莫耶尔的时代。你还记得保罗·莫耶尔吗？记得。然后我们只需要把他的车位挪开，你知道的，挪几个车位。这就好像是，你知道的，花了三天时间谈判才把保罗·莫耶尔的车位挪开。
I do remember... He was not having it. And it was on a Sunday. He wasn't even shooting. Oh, my God. He wasn't even there. He just didn't want his stuff messed with. He just didn't want his spot messed with.
我确实记得……他坚决不同意。而且那是周日。他甚至都没在拍戏。哦，天哪。他当时甚至都不在那里。他就是不想让别人动他的东西。他就是不想让别人动他的车位。
Somehow I remember... I don't know how I'm remembering this. He had a bright... I think it was a bright red 9-11 DP Targa. Like one of those with the big whale tails. I like that. Yeah. Did he cut you off once on follow?
不知怎么的我记得……我不知道我是怎么记住这个的。他有一辆亮红色的……我觉得是一辆亮红色的911 DP Targa。就像那种带有大尾翼的车。我喜欢那个。对。他在追尾时把你挤开过吗？
No, I just remember being taken that a local newsman would have some big-ass flashy, cool car, and he pulled it off. That guy, very, very cool. Yeah. He was a hand-to-hand fight with him in Ron Burgundy. It would be great. It was a very similar kind of, you know...
不，我只是惊讶于一个地方新闻记者竟然有一辆如此牛气冲天、极其拉风的豪车，而且他真的驾驭了它。那家伙，非常非常酷。是的。他和罗恩·勃艮第进行了一场肉搏战。那一定很棒。那是一种非常相似的，你知道的……
Speaking of cool network, newsmen kind of, a little bit of a reach. Your dad was the voice of ABC for all of my years growing up in Los Angeles. Oh, really? Yeah. Like if I played that voice for you, you would knock you out.
说到酷炫的网络新闻记者，有点牵强。在我洛杉矶长大的那些年里，你父亲一直是ABC的御用配音。哦，真的吗？是的。就好像如果我为你播放那个声音，你会被震撼到的。
You'd be like, oh, my God, that's Paul's dad? No question there. I just want to mention that is something very, very cool. Well, actually, so Paul, we've talked about this briefly before once because you mentioned your dad was the voice of ABC, as you said, and he was like the original real promo guy on networks.
你会觉得，哦，天哪，那是保罗的爸爸吗？毫无疑问。我只是想提一下，那是一件非常非常酷的事情。好吧，事实上，保罗，我们以前简单讨论过一次，因为你提到了你父亲是ABC的配音员，正如你所说，他是电视网里最早真正的宣传片配音员。
Yeah. And my recollection is, and so I'm going to say this and then you can tell me what you know about this. And if I'm wrong, he would record the promos for all the network. And the promo guys are, when you watch a show,
是的。我的记忆是，所以我要说出来，然后你可以告诉我你知道多少。如果我记错了，他会为整个电视网录制宣传片。而宣传片配音员就是，当你观看一个节目时，
when you're watching a network and you hear, coming up tonight at 8 p.m., it's an all-new blah-blah-blah, follow it by button. Oh, that was your dad? That was your dad? And your dad would sit in the room with the engineer right next to the board,
当你收看一个电视网，你听到“今晚8点即将播出，这是一档全新节目……”，后面接着一个音效。哦，那是你爸爸？那是你爸爸？然后你爸爸会和工程师一起坐在控制台旁边的房间里，
and he had a 416, a shotgun mic, and he was the first guy to do that in that way. Is that right? I don't know for sure if that's exactly that technical thing, but the image of that shotgun mic, he would never go into the booth. He wanted to do it in the control room.
他拿着一支416枪式麦克风，他是第一个以这种方式这样做的人。是这样吗？我不敢百分之百确定是不是那个具体的科技细节，但那个枪式麦克风的画面，他从来不去录音棚。他想在控制室里做。
Was he, because he was actually in real time telling the guy how to modulate his voice and do all the EQ and stuff? I think that had something to do with it too. And I think he was smart enough or done it enough to know, like, I'm not going in the booth.
他是因为他在实时告诉那个家伙如何调节声音、做各种均衡器之类的吗？我觉得这也有一部分原因。而且我想他足够聪明，或者说做过足够多的次数，知道，比如，我才不去录音棚呢。
I'm gonna be with you guys. It's gonna be exactly the same. I'm not, you know, he also liked to smoke while he was doing it too, and I think the other guy was weird. He really likes that, really does a little of that. Not in the booth, not anymore,
我要和你们在一起。这会完全一样的。我才不，你知道的，他边做边喜欢抽烟，而且我觉得另一个人也挺怪的。他真的很喜欢那样，确实会来那么一手。不在录音棚里，再也不了，
but I will say that, and then we'll get out of the weeds on this. So traditionally, all the voiceover guys, especially in New York, where a lot of it used to be done back in the day, everybody used the mic that's a very common, that I do have over here, and what we refer to as an 87, a U87,
但我得说，然后我们就别在这个细节上纠缠了。所以传统上，所有的配音员，尤其是在纽约，过去很多配音都是在那里完成的，每个人都使用一种非常普遍的麦克风，我这里也正好有一支，我们称之为87，U87，
and it's a great microphone. Oh, thanks. Well, of course. Keep going, 88. Your dad changed that by using that shotgun mic, and he forever changed, and it became the West Coast microphone that also, whenever it would come out here
它是一款伟大的麦克风。哦，谢谢。好吧，当然。继续，88。你父亲通过使用那支枪式麦克风改变了这一点，他永远地改变了它，它成为了西海岸的标志性麦克风，每当它来到这里，
and go to a recording studio, they'd always have a shotgun mic, and it was because of your dad that that became the standard out. Is that like the Johnny Carson one that was on his desk? Is that what a shotgun mic is? What is that? No.
走进录音室，他们总会准备一支枪式麦克风，就是因为你父亲，它才成为了这里的标准配置。那是像约翰尼·卡森桌上那种吗？枪式麦克风是那样的吗？那是什么？不是。
No. Okay, bye, everybody. Oh, see you later, Sean. So, Paul, you did not know that, huh? No, that sounds fantastic to me, and it doesn't seem too far from accurate, even, you know, he did obsess over that kind of stuff,
不是。好吧，大家再见。哦，回头见，肖恩。所以，保罗，你不知道这个，是吧？不，这对我来说听起来太棒了，而且似乎和真实情况相去不远，甚至，你知道的，他对那种事情确实很着迷，
and I probably passed a little bit of it on to me. Were you close to him? Yeah, very. Oh, that's nice. I got to go, you know, I had that opportunity to go to Prospect and Talmage, which was where he would go to work at ABC, and, you know, generally,
我可能也多多少少继承了他这一点。你和他关系亲密吗？对，非常亲密。哦，那太好了。我得去，你知道的，我有机会去Prospect和Talmage，那是他去ABC工作的地方，你知道，一般来说，
that was sort of my first taste of being around anything that was show business related, and that was magical to me. How old were you at that point? Anywhere between the ages of probably five and, you know, nine, 75 to 70. Did it strike you as being like a peculiar thing for your dad to do?
那是我对任何与演艺界相关的事物的第一口尝试，那对我来说太神奇了。那时候你多大？大概在五岁到，你知道的，九岁之间，75到70（此处原文如此）。你觉得你父亲做这件事是一件很奇特的事吗？
I can say from my own experience, and I ask this because I say to my kids sometimes, like, it's when they do stuff, or I do stuff when they come in a work-related environment, I'm like, it's weird, right? Because it's weird to me if my dad had done it, and I sort of acknowledge it. Did it seem strange or just because it was your dad?
我可以根据我自己的经验来说，我之所以这么问，是因为我有时会问我的孩子们，比如，当他们做某些事的时候，或者当他们来到一个与工作相关的环境而我做某些事的时候，我会觉得，这很奇怪，对吧？因为如果我父亲做过的话，我会觉得这很奇怪，我也会承认这一点。这看起来很奇怪，还是仅仅因为那是你爸爸？
It seemed strange only because it was not... I was proud of him, but no one else could recognize this, the pride, you know? It's just such a behind-the-scenes gig. There's nothing kind of famous about it. You don't walk down the street and somebody say, like, wow, there he is, you know? Your dad's a baseball player.
它看起来奇怪，只是因为那不是……我为他感到骄傲，但没有人能认出这种骄傲，你知道吗？这只是一份幕后工作。它没有什么出名的地方。你不会走在街上，然后有人说，哇，他就在那儿，你知道吗？你爸爸是个棒球运动员。
He's like, well, you know, there's no recognition to it, really. But that's what he loved about it so much, was that he could just kind of have this independent life, coyote-ing around town and, you know, doing his work and getting paid for it. So you're sitting there, you're watching kind of the sausage get made for television in some aspect,
就好像，你知道的，它其实没有什么辨识度。但这正是他最喜欢它的地方，他可以过着这种独立的生活，在镇上到处晃悠，你知道，做着他的工作并因此获得报酬。所以你坐在那里，你在某种程度上看着电视香肠是如何制造出来的，
and were you at that point starting to gather these images and interest in this process and what it... Oh, these are the people that are behind the curtain that create at least this lane of fake life. And that started to build an idea for you about what you might want to do, or can you track the moment that you thought, oh, I want to do something like this.
在那时，你是否开始收集这些影像并对这个过程产生兴趣，以及它……哦，这些人就是幕后黑手，至少创造了这种虚假生活的途径。这开始为你建立一个关于你可能想做什么的想法，或者你能追踪到你认为“哦，我想做这样的事情”的那一刻吗？
I can't remember because for as long as my memories are there, I've wanted to make films, for sure. But you have to remember, I mean, Jason, you'll remember, that there was like such a dividing line between making films and making television, you know? Yeah, yeah. Television back then was like, you know, anybody can do it, you know?
我不记得了，因为只要我有记忆开始，我就确定自己想拍电影。但你得记住，我是说，贾森，你会记得，拍电影和拍电视剧之间有一条非常清晰的分界线，你知道的？对，对。当时的电视剧就像是，你知道的，任何人都能拍，你知道的？
Right. Movies was like this gold ring, like not everybody gets to make movies, you know? Right. So you started to experiment with little home movie, and it's not an uncommon story, right? No, it's the same exact story as everybody else. But I had the comradery,
对吧。拍电影就像是一枚金戒指，不是每个人都能拍电影的，你知道的？对吧。所以你开始尝试拍摄小型家庭录影带，这并不是一个罕不寻常的故事，对吧？不，这和其他所有人的故事完全一样。但我有那种情谊，
and it's so crazy. Now, I mean, I look around my life right now, and I see my relationship to all the people in dark rooms that I work with, engineers and things like this, through the entire process of making a movie, and you're like, this is exactly what my dad did. You go to a dark room each day, and, you know, trying to make something happen,
太疯狂了。现在，我是说，我环顾我现在的生话，我看到我和制作电影整个过程中在暗室里一起工作的所有人之间的关系，工程师以及诸如此类的人，你会觉得，这完全就是我父亲所做的事。你每天都去一个暗室，你知道的，试图让某些事情发生，
and the friendships that he had with those guys, I look back, and I think I was really inspired by it. I always just thought that's what a friendship was, you know? He was very close with all these technicians and guys that he worked with, and so those are the people that were around our house. Yeah, one of my first experiences was people that were very, very close with the crew,
他和那些家伙建立的友谊，我回想起来，我觉得我真的深受启发。我一直以为友情就是那样的，你知道的？他与所有这些技术人员和与他合作的家伙非常亲密，所以这些人都是我们家周围的人。是的，我的最初经历之一就是那些与剧组非常非常亲密的人，
or at least a full understanding of the importance of the crew, as opposed to sort of this sort of terrible traditional kind of look at like, oh, you know, some people look at crew as sort of soldiers, and that, you know, the folks that are in front of the camera, the ones that are super important, when the opposite is actually the truth. And so, did that start then understanding that, oh, my God, this is really difficult,
或者至少对剧组的重要性有充分的理解，而不是那种糟糕的传统看法，比如，哦，你知道的，有些人把剧组视为某种士兵，而那些在镜头前的人才是超级重要的人，而实际情况恰恰相反。所以，当时你是否开始明白，哦，天哪，这真的很难，
and there's actually nobody on the set there that doesn't need to be there? Well, the only people that don't need to be there are like studio executives and producers, and you know, what I learned probably from my dad, it was like, whoever's, you know, kick all the people out of the room that are not completely, completely essential to the project. You learn pretty quickly who isn't, you know, they scatter.
而且片场里实际上没有一个人是可有可无的？好吧，唯一不需要在那里的人就像是制片厂高管和制片人，你知道的，我可能从我父亲那里学到的是，把房间里所有对项目并非绝对绝对必不可少的人都赶出去。你很快就会知道谁不是，你知道的，他们会四散奔逃。
Yeah, so grabbing those early video cameras, movie cameras, stuff like that, that sort of pretty common story, where you kind of point a camera at stuff and you kind of take little kid films and little army men, and that's not uncommon. But what about the writing part? Do you remember your first experience looking at a blank piece of paper and trying to figure out how to start from zero?
是的，所以拿起早期的摄像机、电影摄影机之类的东西，这是一种相当普遍的故事，你把镜头对准各种东西，拍一些小孩子的电影和小绿兵，这并不罕见。但是写作部分呢？你还记得你第一次面对一张白纸，试图弄清楚如何从零开始时的经历吗？
Do you remember that being humbling or surprisingly easy? That's a really good question, because I think you're right that the story of, you know, the filmmaker with the eight millimeter camera and then onto the video cameras, like there's a million of them, and that's generally how everybody starts. But the writing part always excited me because I liked it.
你还记得当时觉得这很 humbling（卑微/让人谦卑）还是出奇地容易？这是一个非常好的问题，因为我觉得你是对的，带着8毫米摄像机然后过渡到摄像机的电影制作人的故事，有一百万个，这通常是每个人开始的方式。但写作部分总是让我兴奋，因为我喜欢它。
I think I got lucky that I liked it. I liked putting paper into a typewriter and typing out ideas, and I liked seeing it on the page. I liked looking at that idea. I don't know, from an early age, I've always liked writing and formulating things on paper. And when you learn on a typewriter, you learn how to make it right the first time,
我想我很幸运，我喜欢它。我喜欢把纸塞进打字机里，敲出各种想法，我喜欢在纸页上看到它。我喜欢看着那个想法。我不知道，从小到大，我一直很喜欢写作并在纸上构思事物。当你用打字机学习时，你学会了如何一次就把事情写对，
because the last thing that you want to do is go through that. And I had the one script... You still use a typewriter? No, I don't. From time to time, I will just for fun to mix it up. But no, I don't use a typewriter anymore. But remember the one script that I had, I think I have to credit my mother for this,
因为你最不想做的事情就是经历那种重写。我有一个剧本……你现在还在用打字机吗？不，我不用了。偶尔我会为了好玩而用它来换换口味。但是不，我不再用打字机了。不过还记得我拥有的那个剧本，我想我得把这归功于我母亲，
is I had the script for Holy Grail. Oh, wow. Monty Python. Monty Python? Monty Python. It was published as a little book, and I loved that movie so much. This would be like probably eight,
我当时有《圣杯》的剧本。哦，哇。巨蟒剧团。巨蟒剧团？巨蟒剧团。它被当作一本小书出版了，我太喜欢那部电影了。这大概是78年或79年的事。
seventy-eight or seventy-nine. By the way, they're both like, Monty Python? No, the actual Holy Grail. We're helping Tracy, okay? So I had what was the script for that, and then I just copied that. I just copied how the formatting was of that.
顺便说一句，他们两个都是：巨蟒剧团？不，是真正的《圣杯》。我们在帮特雷西，好吗？所以我当时有那个电影的剧本，然后我就照抄了。我只是照着它的格式抄。
It was a great way to learn. So I think writing is either something that you like doing or you don't like doing. I mean, you know, it's, yeah. I got a dumb, dummy question. What? When you drive, when you're just driving around, like driving around during the day with your kids or whatever,
这是学习的好方法。所以我觉得写作要么是你想做的事，要么是你不想做的事。我是说，你知道的，它，是的。我有一个愚蠢的问题。什么？当你开车时，当你白天开车带着你的孩子们或者随便去哪儿的时候，
do you constantly think in images or see images and think of filmmaking? Like, is it hard to turn it off? Yeah, it's no... It's easy to turn off. Oh, okay, never mind. It's not, no, I don't like walk around like Rain Man or something like that.
你脑子里会不停地出现影像，或者看到影像然后想到电影制作吗？比如，很难关掉这个开关吗？是的，这不……很容易关掉。哦，好吧，打扰了。不是的，不，我不会像《雨人》那样到处乱晃。
Because I always think of like, like whenever I'm driving around, I always see like images. There's like, God, there'd be such, and I see like a frame around it or something. I'm not a filmmaker. Especially when you listen to music, do you find that happening, Sean?
因为我总觉得像，每当我开车的时候，我总是能看到像影像一样的画面。就觉得，天哪，这会是如此，我看到周围有个框或者别的什么。我可不是个电影制作人。特别是当你听音乐的时候，你发现会这样吗，肖恩？
All the time. Right? You basically start cutting videos, right? Yeah, don't you do that, Sean? On the big beat change, your eyes go right, you know? And I dork out like that. How many, how many Wham inspired movies have you made, Sean, in your head?
总是这样。对吧？你基本上开始剪辑视频了，对吧？是的，你不是也那样吗，肖恩？在重音转换时，你的眼睛就会往右看，你知道吗？我就会像那样犯傻。肖恩，你脑子里拍了多少部受威猛乐队（Wham）启发的电影？
Oh, there's got to be like 12. I mean, you know, they wake me up before you go, go was my holy grail. I understand. You know, they're like, I was like, I can't believe there's just... It just lends itself to a real cinematic. Paul, what was it?
哦，大概得有12部吧。我是说，你知道的，他们把我吵醒之前你走吧走吧就是我的圣杯。我明白。你知道的，他们就像是，我当时想，我简直不敢相信有这样……它太适合拍成电影了。保罗，那是什么？
This could be the best interview. Just, I like, I just... You don't get to talk, Paul. I know, and this is why I like it. I just want to hear you guys. I have to tell you, my favorite, I listen to, I don't listen to... You haven't listened to this.
这可能是最棒的采访。就是，我喜欢，我只是……你都说不上话，保罗。我知道，这就是我喜欢它的原因。我只想听你们说。我必须告诉你，我最喜欢的，我听的，你没听过这个。
I have, of course I have, but the one joke that stuck with me forever and ever and ever was Will sing something about your father, Jason, and he, and by father, he met the security guard at the 20th Century Fox. That sounds about right. Don't make Jason cry. Don't make Jason cry.
我有，我当然听过，但那个永远永远留在我的记忆深处的笑话是，威尔唱了一首关于你父亲的歌，贾森，然后他，所谓的父亲指的是二十世纪福克斯的保安。听起来差不多。别把贾森弄哭了。别把贾森弄哭了。
It stuck with me where I think about, that's what I think about, John, when I'm driving down the road every once in a while, I'll think about something pops into your head. You think, God, that was really, really, really, really funny, you know. It's surprising when you're in the car and you're driving around,
它一直留在我的脑海里，以至于我想起，约翰，当我偶尔开车在路上行驶时，我会想起有些东西突然跳进你的脑海。你会想，天哪，那真的、真的、真的、真的很好笑，你知道吗。当你坐在车里到处开车时，这挺让人意外的，
you're not thinking about Sean's dad peeling away from the house. Because he was real handy in a car. Yeah, still hasn't come back. Exactly. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Paul, and forgive us for just being such fools.
你居然没有在想肖恩的爸爸从家里开车绝尘而去的情景。因为他在车里真的很有一手。对，到现在还没回来。没错。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。保罗，请原谅我们表现得像个傻瓜。
I'm sure we ruin many of your days having to listen to it, but wait, I want to know about, I want to know about, Okay, just cut him off, Sean. If you get an idea, start talking. Go ahead, Will. Wait, I just want to get this out of the way. I think I've seen, I'm pretty sure
我确信我们毁了你很多天不得不听这些废话的心情，但是等等，我想知道，我想知道，好吧，直接打断他，肖恩。如果你有了想法，就开始说。说吧，威尔。等等，我只是想把这个说出来。我想我见过，我很确信
I've seen every single one of your films and always been amazed by each one, but I just want to get this out of the way before I forget. Boogie Nights. Is it true that Leo was up for the part, but Mark got it, or Leo turned it down because he did Titanic, or is there any truth to any of that?
我看过你的每一部电影，并且总是对每一部都惊叹不已，但我只是想在忘记之前把这个问出来。《不羁夜》。里奥曾经争取过这个角色，但马克得到了，或者里奥因为拍了《泰坦尼克号》而拒绝了，这些传闻有哪怕一点是真的吗？
Sean loves the dirt, Paul. That is very true, is that I asked Leo to be in Boogie Nights, and he spent many, many months agonizing and debating about it. Months. And ultimately, what I didn't realize or kind of came to realize
肖恩喜欢泥土，保罗。这非常真实，我曾请利奥出演《不羁夜》，他为此痛苦纠结了许多许多个月。好几个月。最终，我没有意识到或者说渐渐意识到的是
about halfway into that, this sort of long decision-making process is that he had a choice to make, which was to either do Titanic or to do Boogie Nights, and he chose to do Titanic, which, of course, in the long run, catapulted him to this massive worldwide fame,
保罗，肖恩就爱打听八卦。那是千真万确的，我确实邀请过里奥出演《不羁夜》，他花了整整好几个月的时间来痛苦纠结和争论这件事。几个月。最终，我没有意识到或者说逐渐意识到
but on the other hand, I think possibly, but I think it was, we laugh about it now, but he regrets missing the experience and doing it, but yeah, that's true. Yeah, that's right. I just always wondered that.
在这个漫长的决策过程进行到一半时，他面临一个选择，要么去拍《泰坦尼克号》，要么去拍《不羁夜》，他选择了《泰坦尼克号》，当然，从长远来看，这把他推向了巨大的世界名气，但另一方面，我想可能，不过我觉得，我们现在拿这个开玩笑，但他很遗憾错失了这段经历和拍摄机会，不过是的，那是真的。
Well, now you know. Well, yeah, I would have never known. Will, was your question as good as that? Not as good as that. Actually, that was very interesting and well done, Sean. Congrats. I like the idea. Back to Google.
是的，没错。我一直很好奇这个。好吧，现在你知道了。好吧，是的，我永远也不会知道。威尔，你的问题和那个一样好吗？没有那个好。其实，那个非常有趣而且问得很好，肖恩。祝贺你。我喜欢这个主意。回到谷歌。
Back to Google, Sean. Go ahead, Will. I thought you were going to say, and to this day, I still think Leo made a huge error in judgment. You never let it go. But what was... No, the question actually was just simply,
回到谷歌，肖恩。说吧，威尔。我还以为你要说的是，直到今天我仍然认为里奥做出了一个巨大的判断失误。你永远放不下这个。但当时的是……不，这个问题其实很简单，
what was that first thing that you wrote and you said, I should film this. Yeah. And that first thing that you actually put to film, that you, from your own words. Well, I did like short treatments and shot lists and things like that,
你写的第一部作品是什么，然后你说，我应该把它拍成电影。是的。那是你真正付诸胶片的第一部作品，完全出自你自己的构思。好吧，我确实做过一些简短的故事大纲和分镜头脚本之类的事情，
but really funny enough that when I was 16, just about to turn 17, I wrote a short film that was called The Dirk Diggler Story, that was what Boogie Nights became. And it was like a 23 or 24-page script. But I did it in the format that was a little popular at the time.
但非常有趣的是，当我16岁，快要17岁的时候，我写了一部名为《德克·迪格勒的故事》的短片，这就是《不羁夜》的雏形。那是一个大约23或24页的剧本。但我采用了当时比较流行的一种格式。
And all I had was this sort of bad video camera, so I realized it wasn't going to look good. It wasn't going to look like a movie. So I wrote this thing that was about 23 pages long and it was interviews with people looking back at the life of this guy, Dirk Diggler. Oh, a current affair was a very popular show at that time. If you remember that,
我当时只有这种糟糕的摄像机，所以我意识到它拍出来不会好看。它看起来不像一部电影。所以我写了这个大约23页长的东西，内容是对一些人的采访，他们回顾了这个叫德克·迪格勒的家伙的一生。哦，《当今美国》是当时非常受欢迎的一个节目。如果你还记得的话，
they would always have these insanely over dramatic, and it was so preposterous that it was so trying to find a way into the story that I thought was interesting, which is the pornography that had surrounded me my whole life living where I lived. It was so obvious what was around me. And then writing it in this format was like a doable thing.
他们总是会有这些疯狂的、过度戏剧化的内容，而且它是如此荒谬，以至于我试图找到一种我認為有趣的方式来切入这个故事，那就是我生活的地方周围一直环绕着的色情业。我周围的一切都太明显了。然后用这种格式把它写下来是一件可行的事情。
Like, okay, I can get somebody and do an interview with them. I mean, it's a format that's still at work, but at the time it was really like the most convenient and plausible way into a story with the equipment that you had at hand. Have you transferred that from, was it VHS? No, it was eight millimeter, eight millimeter video,
就像，好吧，我可以找个人来采访他们。我是说，这是一种至今仍然管用的格式，但在当时，这确实是用你手头现有的设备切入故事最便捷、最貌似合理的方法。你把它转存过吗，是VHS格式吗？不，是8毫米的，8毫米录像带，
so a high eight, I think. Have you transferred it to something that will last and are we ever going to see it? Hopefully not. Hopefully it's somewhere. No, it's transferred within an inch of its life. It's available. I think maybe it's on YouTube.
所以我认为是高8（Hi8）格式。你把它转存到能保存很久的媒介上了吗，我们还有机会看到它吗？希望不会。希望它待在某个地方。不，它已经被转存了无数次了。它是可以找到的。我想也许它在YouTube上。
I'd have to look again. Yeah, I'm not sure. Wow. It's not terrible. There's still some jokes that are the same and some pieces that remained in Boogie Nights. What was great about that was that what I didn't even realize at the time
我得再去看看。是的，我不确定。哇。它其实没那么糟糕。里面仍然有一些相同的笑话，以及一些保留在《不羁夜》中的片段。最棒的是，当时我甚至都没有意识到
in terms of the writing, in terms of really learning how to write was that I'd created this kind of these fictional characters in this fake documentary. And then I realized what I had to do was adapt that, adapt these fake lives into a movie. And I spent the next, well, probably about 10 years doing that. So I wrote a 90 page version of this documentary.
在写作方面，在真正学会如何写作方面，我在这部伪纪录片中创造了这些虚构的角色。然后我意识到我必须要做的是改编它，把这些虚构的生活改编成一部电影。在接下来的，嗯，大概10年里我都在做这件事。所以我写了这个伪纪录片的90页版本。
And then I realized, well, I don't want to do that. That's not the right format for this. I want to write this as a fictional film. So I did that for 10 years. I guess it was the way that I learned how to write, really, was practicing telling this story in multiple different ways. Tony, that seems to be a recurring theme with a lot of filmmakers and writers.
然后我意识到，好吧，我不想这么做。这不是这个故事正确的格式。我想把它写成一部虚构电影。所以我花了10年时间做这件事。我想这就是我真正学会写作的方式，通过以多种不同的方式练习讲述这个故事。托尼，这似乎是许多电影制作人和作家身上一个反复出现的主题。
I know Kenny Lonergan used to do, back in Naked Angels in this theater company in New York in the 90s, he did various scene nights on Monday nights where he would do the scene about a brother and a sister and then just this guy who was kind of lost in his 20s in New York, et cetera, et cetera. And it took on a bunch of different incarnations, a bunch of different scenes,
我知道肯尼·洛纳根过去常做这件事，回到90年代纽约的这个叫Naked Angels的剧团，他在周一晚上举办各种场景之夜，他会排演一个关于兄弟姐妹的场景，然后只是一个在纽约20多岁有点迷茫的家伙，诸如此类，诸如此类。它经历了好几种不同的化身，好几种不同的场景，
which eventually then became, this is our youth, the play, that my then girlfriend, Missy Yeager, was in with Mark Ruffalo and Josh Hamilton, that then became kind of really, I think the inspiration for You Can Count on Me. But it was like this similar story, similar theme that he told in various ways over at least 15 years before he kind of landed on that.
最终演变成了话剧《这是我们的青春》，我当时的女友米西·耶格尔曾和马克·鲁法洛、乔什·汉密尔顿一起出演过这部话剧，这后来真的成为了我認為《你办事我放心》的灵感来源。但这就像是一个相似的故事，相似的主题，他在至少15年的时间里以各种方式讲述着它，直到他最终敲定那个版本。
I'm sure you can probably relate to that. For sure, you know, maybe there's leftovers and you're just, I don't know how deep is your well, I guess, you just keep it. Well, to that point, I mean, do you find that it was basically a peel in the onion further and further back on a specific theme that you thought this sort of story was a fun example of?
我确信你大概能对此感同身受。当然，你知道的，也许会有一些剩余的素材，然后你只是，我不知道你的灵感之井有多深，我想，你只是把它保留下来。好吧，说到这一点，你有没有发现，这基本上就是在一层又一层地剥开洋葱，去剖析一个你认为这种故事是一个有趣例子的特定主题？
And if so, what is that theme? Yeah, but that's a, can you write a theme? I can never write a theme. Well, I mean, but I mean, you tell me, you know what you're doing, a theme of being, let's say, the irresponsible chase of fame. No, I never have anything good like that. I always have like, just like, I never ever have,
如果是这样的话，那个主题是什么？是的，但是，你能写出一个主题吗？我从来写不出主题。好吧，我是说，但我的意思是，你告诉我，你知道自己在做什么，比如对某种主题的追求，比方说，对名声不负责任的追逐。不，我从来没有过那么好的东西。我总是只有像，比如，真实发生过的事情，有些是从现实生活中偷师的，比如，每个故事本质上都是一样的，你知道的，就好像，夸张的版本是一个刚下公交车的人，
I have more like facts, like, well, what really happens here and some steal from real life, like, every story was essentially the same, you know, it was like, if the exaggerated version was the guy who steps off the bus and, you know, kind of comes to Hollywood with big dreams and takes his pants off. And then the next thing, you know, he's a big star and it was any classic rise and fall story.
你知道的，带着伟大的梦想来到好莱坞，然后脱掉了裤子。接着你知道的，他成了一名大明星，这就是任何经典的起伏跌宕的故事。所以我总是只是顺着现实的脚步走。我是说，我不知道，我从来没有，我对围绕着一个主题写作或者事先有任何那种东西感到非常害怕。我记得在某个特定时刻，也许需要帮助，比如，这个故事是什么？幸运的是，我偶然看到了《雨中曲》，然后觉得，哦，对了，这不就跟有声片取代默片是一样的吗，你知道的，
So I'm always just sort of following any steps of reality. I mean, I don't know, I never, I get so scared of writing to a theme or having anything like that beforehand. I can remember at a certain point, maybe needing help, like, what is the story? And luckily enough, coming across singing in the rain and being like, oh, right, it's just the same thing as like silent talkies, you know,
这是任何行业中从胶片拍摄过渡到视频拍摄的转型期。像这样利用事物来讲述你的故事，无论什么主题都会在稍后自然浮现。好吧，是的，所以你写了一个故事，你基本上只是写了一个剧本，因为简单化来说。这个事件发展到那个事件，再到这个事件和那个事件，
it's this transitional time in whatever industry they're going from shooting on film to shooting on video. Like, use things like this to tell your story and whatever themes will just emerge later. Well, yes, so you write a story and you basically just write a script because it's to oversimplify it. This event runs to this event and this event and this event
现在我们有了一个结局，这是一个有趣的故事，然后你把它拍出来，一切都进展顺利，现在你来到了剪辑室。你开始塑造这个——请原谅我借用这个词——献给观众的体验。它开始以电影的形式呈现出来，你开始使用临时音乐或真正的配乐，也许主题开始发展
and now we have an ending and it's a fun story and now you shoot it and all that worked out well and now you're in the editing room. And you start to shape this, pardon the phrase, experience for the audience. And it starts to sort of present itself as a film and you start working with either temp music or the actual score and maybe themes start to develop
对你而言，作为一个观众，当你正在观看它时，试着保持观众的视角。你允许这种情况发生吗，然后这会影响你完成电影的方式吗？哦，这里有一个隐藏在这个略显生硬的故事底下的有趣的小主题。你发现这种情况会发生吗？我发现这正是发生的事情，唯一的例外是
for you as a viewer, as you're viewing it, trying to keep the optics of a viewer. Do you allow that to happen and then does that inform the way you finish the film and oh, here's a little theme that's existing underneath this crunchy story that's kind of fun. Does that, do you find that that happens? I find that that's exactly what happens with the exception
它发生得稍微早一点，你知道的，一旦你，我是说，我不瞎，你知道的，当你在写某些东西时，你可能在抗拒这样一种想法，即主题就摆在你的面前，仅仅是因为你试图真实地讲述某些事情，而最终浮现的东西自然会浮现，你无法抗拒，希望你会喜欢它。
that it does happen a little bit earlier, you know, that once you, I mean, I'm not blind, you know, as you're writing something, you may be, you're fighting off the idea that the theme is right in front of your face, just because you want to try to tell something factually and what ends up emerging emerges and you can't fight it, hopefully you like it,
这确实发生得有点早，你知道的，一旦你——我的意思是，我并不瞎，你知道的，在你写作的时候，你可能一直在抗拒“主题就摆在眼前”这种想法，仅仅是因为你想尽可能客观地叙述事实，而最终浮现的东西就是浮现了，你无法抗拒，希望你会喜欢它，
you're enjoying what's happening. But you, I think, and you keep a half an eye on it, but really you keep the other eye on what are the facts? What are the facts? What are the facts of the story? Why is that? Because I don't know, I find films that overindulge in telling me the theme are annoying, you know, and boring.
你很享受这个过程。但我觉得，你一方面会关注它，但实际上你另一眼盯着的是什么？是事实是什么？事实是什么？这个故事的真实情况是什么？为什么会这样？因为我不知道，我觉得那些过度沉迷于向我灌输主题的电影很烦人，你知道，而且很无聊。
So, but yes, to your point that once you, and then you get into shooting and you're seeing dailies and you're seeing stuff emerge that is really exciting or stuff that is unexpected and you either embrace it or you say, perhaps this is not going in the right direction, but very, more often than not, you can't stop what's coming,
所以，不过是的，正如你所说，一旦你开始拍摄，你看到了样片，看到了真正令人兴奋的事情浮现，或者看到了意想不到的东西，你要么拥抱它，要么会说，也许这没有朝着正确的方向发展，但更多时候，你无法阻挡即将发生的事情，
nor should you that you have to kind of be surrender. You're guiding a ship, but you're also surrendering a bit to the path that's happening and, you know, performances kind of get bigger or smaller, whatever ends up happening. And then it just keeps on going and you keep refining that through the editing and all that. One of the, if we can get into staying on the idea of themes,
也不应该阻挡，你必须顺其自然。你是在驾驶一艘船，但你同时也对正在发生的一切半推半就、顺其自然，你知道，表演可能会变得更夸张或更收敛，无论最终结果如何。然后它就会一直进行下去，你在剪辑的过程中不断提炼，诸如此类。如果我们继续探讨主题这个概念，
one of the themes of, it seems to me of your films, is that they're very specific, visually and stylistically, each one different in its own way, but you, they do seem so specific in the writing and so what is your relationship like, again, going deeper into the weeds on filmmaking, but what is your relationship like with your production designer and your DP leading up to when you actually shoot
在我看来，你的电影的主题之一，就是它们在视觉和风格上都非常具体，每一部都有其独特之处，但在剧本创作中它们确实显得非常具体。那么，更深入地探讨电影制作的细节，在你实际开拍之前，你和你的美术指导以及摄影指导（DP）之间的关系是怎样的？
because it does seem like all of your films, I told you once at risk of further embarrassment to myself and to you, you know, for instance, There Will Be Blood, I feel like it should be just hung in MoMA and left there for people to watch. It's an incredible piece of art in every way, from the writing to the direction,
因为你的所有电影看起来确实都——我曾经对你说过，冒着让自己和你进一步尴尬的风险，你知道，比如《血色将至》，我觉得它就应该挂在现代艺术博物馆（MoMA）里，让人们去观赏。它在方方面面都是一件不可思议的艺术品，从剧本到导演，
to the art direction, the production. What is that like for you leading up to actually rolling film and working with those departments? Well, it's the great joy of collaboration, particularly when you're doing it with somebody that you love and work with. Like, for instance, on that film, I had never worked with Jack Fisk,
再到美术指导、制片。在真正开机拍摄以及与这些部门合作之前，对你来说那是怎样的一段经历？嗯，那是合作的巨大乐趣，特别是当你和自己热爱并共事的人一起合作时。比如，在那部电影中，我从未和杰克·菲斯克合作过，
who's one of the great production designers who started his career with Terrence Malick and David Lynch. They kind of go back to their beginnings together. Anyway, I contacted Jack Fisk and had written the script and I needed to kind of create, I need a lot of help with making oil derricks and the recreation of an early California town and there was only one person that helped do that,
他是最伟大的美术指导之一，他的职业生涯是从与泰伦斯·马力克和大卫·林奇合作开始的。他们从一开始就有些渊源。总之，我联系了杰克·菲斯克，当时我已经写好了剧本，我需要建立——我在制作油井和重现早期加州小镇方面需要大量帮助，而只有一个人能帮我做到这一点，
so it started a great collaboration. Jack Fisk was, you know, we were kind of trying to learn how to get oil out of the ground and really trying to be really, you know, do our research and he said the greatest thing. He's like, you know, I found that if we can just get a children's book about this, it's really better than trying to really understand how to do it
于是这开启了一段伟大的合作。杰克·菲斯克，你知道，我们当时正在努力学习如何从地下采油，并且真的在努力进行研究，他说了一句绝妙的话。他说，你知道，我发现如果我们能找到一本关于这个的儿童读物，真的比试图通过所有这些厚厚的书来真正理解怎么做要好得多，
with all these kind of books that are this thick. And it was one of these great lessons in like, yeah, get the children's book first and don't be, you know, because it'll have drawings, it'll be simple. And it was like, wow, Jack Fisk gets the children's book first. All right, that's really good advice. But we had the incredible joy of going to scout locations together and find a place to make this film
这些书有这么厚。这是最棒的教训之一，就像是，对，先看儿童读物，不要，你知道的，因为它会有图画，它会很简单。当时我就想，哇，杰克·菲斯克竟然先看儿童读物。好吧，这真的是个好建议。但我们一起去堪景、寻找拍摄地，有着无与伦比的快乐，
and I learned from him one incredible trick that I still try to sort of make true is that the more you can have a location where everything's close together, the more freedom you have. Here's what I mean by that, is that if you shoot a scene, you know, over here and you see it a few days later, you think that's the worst scene that we've ever done.
我从他身上学到了一个不可思议的诀窍，我至今仍试图将其付诸实践：那就是，外景地越集中、每样东西都靠得越近，你拥有的自由度就越大。我的意思是，如果你在一个地方拍了一场戏，你知道，过了几天后回看，觉得那是我们拍过的最烂的一场戏，
We should really try to do it again, is that you can go do it again. You know, you kind of create your own, you create your own back lock, you create your own universe and try as much as you possibly can to not move too much but to have a variety of different looks and things happening. So that, I don't know, I'm lost in whatever your question was,
我们真的应该再拍一次，那你就可以回去重新拍。你知道，你有点在创造你自己的后盾，创造你自己的宇宙，并尽可能地做到不要频繁转移场地，而是要有各种不同的视觉效果和事情发生。所以，我不知道，我被你的问题绕晕了，大概就是关于合作，那……
it was kind of like the collaboration, that's... Well, the simplicity sometimes yields some of the most complex and sophisticated results perhaps, yeah. Sure, that's my role. Was there a similar process with Johnny Greenwood, who did the, for Tracy, was the composer on that film? I believe it was the first time he'd composed music for a film and the first time you guys worked together?
嗯，简单有时反而会产生最复杂、最成熟的效果，也许吧。当然，这是我的角色。与为《性本恶》（注：台译，这里指《霓裳魅影》或《狂载原声》等，听语境应指早期合作者）创作音乐的强尼·格林伍德（Johnny Greenwood）是否有过类似的合作过程？我记得那是他第一次为电影创作音乐，也是你们第一次合作？
Yeah, yeah. There was a piece of music that he had written for orchestra because he was already well-versed in how to write for string instruments. It wasn't like, don't let him fool you. I mean, I know he's... But obviously, his score was incredible, as was everything else in the film.
对，对。他曾经为管弦乐队写过一段音乐，因为他当时已经精通如何为弦乐器谱曲。这并不是说——别让他把你给骗了。我的意思是，我知道他……但显然，他的配乐棒极了，电影中的其他一切也是如此。
It is really incredible and it's an opportunity. You know, look, I think... No, there was no kind of crazy weird instrumentation or something like that. He does do funny things with instruments where he'll detune certain pieces of the orchestra and keep others in tune. And so he has the ability to make it sound very familiar. You're hearing string instruments,
确实非常不可思议，这是一个机会。你知道，听着，我想……不，没有什么疯狂诡异的乐器配置之类的。他在乐器上的确会做一些有趣的事情，比如他会把管弦乐队的某些部分调失准，而让其他部分保持准音。因此，他有能力让音乐听起来非常熟悉，你听到的是弦乐器，
but that sounds just out of body enough that you can't quite place it. So he's brilliant like that, but that's sort of stuff. You know, it's nice, it's trickery, but he writes beautiful music that complements the film and they go hand in hand. It was the beginning of a beautiful collection. Do you constantly keep that in mind when you're writing?
但那种声音又足够出神入化，让你一时间说不上来是什么。他就是这么才华横溢，但诸如此类的事情，你知道，这很好，这是一种小把戏，但他写出了与电影相辅相成的美妙音乐，它们相得益彰。这是一段美好合作关系的开始。你在写作时一直把这些记在心里吗？
Like spaces or do you listen to stuff when you write? Yeah, for sure. I mean, I had all kinds of... The stuff that I was listening to was stuff that he likes anyway. Was it Penderecki or Schubert or, you know, even the piece that he had written for the BPC orchestra. So that was already kind of informing where my head was at. And it was nice to go to him and say like, you know,
比如空间感，或者你写作时会听些什么吗？对，当然。我的意思是，我听过各种各样的东西……我当时听的音乐本来就是他喜欢的。是潘德列茨基（Penderecki）还是舒伯特，或者，你知道，甚至是他为英国广播公司（BBC）管弦乐团写的那首曲子。所以这些已经为我当时的思路奠定了基础。去找他说这些感觉真好，你知道，
the movie lends itself too to just like wide open spaces and like a huge opportunity to fill long gaps of silence with music that can either be gigantically loud or even just simmering underneath. So it was quite a good entrance into the game for him. I love that. What's the music that you put on when you go like pick up the kids from school or whatever?
这部电影本身也很适合那种开阔的空间，并且是一个极好的机会，可以用那些或宏大轰鸣、或在底层暗流涌动的音乐，来填补大段大段的沉默。所以对他来说，这是进入这个行业的一个相当不错的起点。我太喜欢了。你去接孩子们放学或者干嘛的时候，会放什么音乐？
Like what are your bands? Yeah, what's the music you have to take off the stereo when your kids get in and put on... Well, they're already sick of that smile record. They've been hearing that enough. They're like, they're like enough with that. Enough, enough, enough. So, well, come on.
比如你们常听哪些乐队？对，当你的孩子们上车时，你得把音响关掉并换成什么音乐……嗯，他们已经对那张“微笑”唱片感到厌烦了。他们听得够多的了。他们会说，他们会觉得那够了。够了，够了，够了。所以，好吧，得了吧。
What's Pearl listening to right now? Pearl is listening to... Well, you know what she's listening to is anything, and I don't know in any of the many of the artists, but we just, we're kind of obsessed right now with this film, The Worst Person in the World. I don't know if you guys have seen it. I've seen the trailer. It looks great.
珀尔（Pearl）现在在听什么？珀尔在听……嗯，你知道她听的其实是什么都听，虽然我不知道其中许多艺术家的名字，但我们现在对这部电影《世界上最糟糕的人》有点着迷。我不知道你们有没有看过。我看过预告片。看起来很棒。
Oh, it's fucking magical, this film, and it's got this great soundtrack. So we've just kind of been listening to all this variety of songs on that soundtrack, which is everything from like Harry Nielsen and Todd Rungering to a lot of new stuff that I've never heard in my life, you know. I want to ask you something about, you know, streaming versus wide release and where we're at
哦，这部电影他妈的太神奇了，而且它的原声带太棒了。所以我们最近一直在听这张原声带里的各种歌曲，从哈里·尼尔森（Harry Nilsson）和托德·伦格伦（Todd Rundgren），到很多我这辈子从未听过的新音乐，你知道的。我想问你一个关于，你知道的，流媒体与大规模院线上映的对比，以及我们现在所处的行业现状，
in the business of that, and, you know, having this conversation with a friend. And we were talking about how, for example, West Side Story or Licorice Pizza or whatever it is that's out there that's fantastic right now, how that would have fared with a really long, wide release run. Would anybody see these things?
你知道的，和朋友进行这样的对话。我们在讨论，比如《西区故事》或《甘草比萨》或者现在上映的任何极其精彩的电影，如果进行真正长期的大规模院线发行，它们的表现会怎样？还会有人看这些东西吗？
Are we really truly at the point where we just want to see stuff in our homes, but to the filmmaker, I imagine, you want it to be seen on that big screen because of the genre of filmmaking, right? Because of the thing that lends itself to that. So what are your thoughts about that? Well, yeah, I mean, I don't know. I kind of like everything, you know what I mean?
我们是不是真的已经到了这样一个地步：我们只想在家里看电影，但对于电影制作人来说，我猜，因为这种电影的类型，你还是希望它能在那个大银幕上被观看，对吧？因为这种题材本身就适合那样。所以你对此有什么看法？好吧，是的，我的意思是，我不知道。我基本上什么都喜欢，你知道我的意思吗？
I really do. I sound like Daniel Plainview is like, I like all kinds of religions. They're all fucking, you know. And then he sticks it in your back. Exactly. But when you make a movie, isn't the idea in your head, I can't wait to see this on the big screen.
我是认真的。我听起来就像丹尼尔·普兰维尤（Daniel Plainview），说“我喜欢各种宗教，它们他妈的都……”然后他就从背后捅你一刀。完全正确。但当你拍电影时，你脑子里的想法难道不是：我迫不及待地想在大银幕上看到它。
Yes. Right. Absolutely. And so with the business of this business, it just seems to be less and less that if it's not one of these big superhero movies, it's going to... Well, listen, that's exactly right. I mean, to that point is there's probably, you know,
是的。没错。绝对是这样。所以随着这个行业的发展，这种现象似乎越来越少见，如果不是那些超级英雄大电影，它就会……好吧，听着，完全正确。我的意思是，说到这一点，在这个国家里可能只有，
30 theaters in this country where it would look great and sound great and the rest are fucking filth. I'm sorry, but it's like, you know, and that's the sad truth of it is that I can understand why everybody says like, oh, piss off. I'm staying at home. You know, you want me to pay for babysitter and pay for parking and come in and look at this shit
30家影院能让它看起来很棒、听起来很棒，而其余的影院他妈的都是垃圾。对不起，但事实就是这样，你知道的，这就是悲惨的真相，我可以理解为什么每个人都说：“哦，滚开。我待在家里。”你知道的，你想让我花钱请保姆、花钱停车，然后来看这堆狗屎，
and look at it on a fucking screen that you guys haven't even, you know, I don't know. It's hard to defend at a certain point. Yeah. But I'm sure that if God forbid that the business became a place where it's only event movies in theaters and the only place that you can expect your film to be seen is at home based on it's not a big effects thing
而且是在一个你们甚至连——我不知道，你们连一块像样的银幕都没有的破地方看。在某种程度上，这真的很难为它辩护。是的。但我确信，如果上帝保佑，电影行业真的变成了一个只有活动大片才能进影院、而你的电影唯一能被看到的地方就是家里——因为这不是那种大特效电影或者其他什么原因，
or whatever, you'd much rather people see a film, be able to make films and have them see it at home than make no films at all. Right, but I don't know. I think that's kind of bullshit too because the reason why is when all these theaters were opening up again, you know, you have these huge, gigantic 25 plexes and stuff like that
比起拍不成任何电影，你肯定更愿意让人们看一部电影，能拍电影并让他们在家里看。对吧，但我不知道。我觉得这也是一堆废话，因为原因在于，当所有这些影院重新开业时，你知道，你有那些巨大的、拥有25个厅的庞大综合影院之类的，
and everybody was crying, oh, they're empty. It was like, well, what did you fucking think was gonna happen? But if you go to any of the great theaters, let's say in Los Angeles or New York that are playing specialty programming, they're packed with people. Right. They're all turning out.
然后每个人都在哭喊，哦，它们是空的。这就好像是，好吧，你他妈以为会发生什么？但如果你去任何一家优秀的影院，比方说洛杉矶或纽约那些播放特色节目的影院，它们都挤满了人。没错。人们都倾巢而出了。
They're film lovers, they're people that you know are gonna come out and turn out for this thing and because there's one theater with 400 seats that they can fill and they can do two shows a day or three shows a day and people will still turn up. It was like everyone's scratching their head. No one's coming back for the movies. It's like, well, they're not coming back
他们是影迷，你知道他们会为了这东西而倾巢而出，因为那里有一个拥有400个座位的影院，他们可以坐满，每天可以放映两场或三场，人们依然会捧场。这就好像每个人都在挠头，说“没人再回电影院了”。这就好像是，好吧，他们才不会回到我们建造的那些怪异可怕的金字塔里去呢。
to these weird horrible pyramids that we've built. But Paul, I think that maybe you're saying, and I don't wanna put words in your mouth, but there is a little bit of, well, of course they're not gonna come back because look what you're putting in the theaters is part of the problem A. And I can say that and I know it's hard for you to say
但保尔，我觉得你可能在说——我不想替你做决定——但其中确实有一点，嗯，他们当然不会回来，因为看看你放在影院里的都是些什么，这就是问题A的一部分。我可以这么说，而且我知道对你来说很难开口，
because of your position in the films that you make and you probably don't wanna be that guy who says that. But you make the kind of films that you want that are really incredible films and at the same time you don't seek out recognition for yourself in a way that a lot of other filmmakers seem to do. It's never about your own sort of,
因为你在你所拍摄的电影中所处的位置，你可能不想成为那个说这种话的人。但你拍的是你想拍的那种真正不可思议的电影，与此同时，你并不像许多其他电影制作人那样去刻意寻求自我认可。这从来都不是为了你自己的那种，
you know, increasing your personal fame. So my question to you is how much of that are you aware of show business in fact or are you kind of in your bubble of making the films that you make? No, I do and then I don't. I slip in and out of it because I love, part of loving movies as much as I do,
你知道的，增加个人名气。所以我的问题是，你对好莱坞名利场的现实意识有多少？还是说你只是活在你自己的拍片泡沫里？不，我既有这种意识，又没有。我在其中进进出出，因为我热爱——部分原因是我太热爱电影了，
the history of movies and my, you know, my obsession with this work, which has been with me forever and what I've made of my life, it does involve being fascinated with the way that it moves, you know, like we were talking about, we were singing in the rain, you know, that's a fantastic story,
电影的历史，以及我——你知道的，我对这项工作的痴迷，它永远伴随着我，它构成了我的生活——这确实需要对它运作的方式保持着迷，你知道的，就像我们之前讨论的，我们谈到《雨中曲》，你知道，那是一个了不起的故事，
the way that what happened to the movie business when it changed from talkies to, so I constantly try to keep an eye on that or try to understand it or have enough friends in this business from over the years that I can call up and ask, you know, what does this mean? What does this mean when this film is doing well
当电影行业从有声片转型时所发生的事情，所以我不断地试图关注这一点，或者试图理解它，或者在这些年里在这个行业里有足够多的朋友，我可以打电话问他们，你知道，这意味着什么？当这部电影表现出色时，这意味着什么？
or what is gonna happen here? What ties do you see turning? And it's nice to gauge that stuff. I love this business and I love movies so much that I have a real interest in seeing it survive, but more often than not, the volume of my day becomes more about film preservation, you know, and film history and trying to keep that stuff alive
或者这里会发生什么？你看到潮流发生了什么转变？评估这些事情感觉很好。我太热爱这个行业和电影了，以至于我真的很有兴趣看到它生存下去，但更多时候，我每天的大部分时间都花在了电影保护上，你知道，还有电影历史，试图让那些东西保持活力，
and then just sort of looking to see what's happening and reacting, I suppose, but I don't know. How often do you collaborate with Quentin Tarantino on those efforts? Because I know he's got a real passion for the history of cinema and turning people on to stuff that perhaps I haven't seen.
然后只是顺便看看发生了什么并做出反应，我想，但我不知道。你多久与昆汀·塔伦蒂诺（Quentin Tarantino）在这些工作上合作一次？因为我知道他对电影史有着真正的热情，并且会向人们安利一些可能我还没看过的东西。
He's great about all that, but he's amazing about it, one of the best, but he also really runs in his own lane, you know, because the person who I collaborate the most with that is Scorsese because he has the Film Foundation. He, since the 70s, since the late 70s, early 80s, went around to every studio in town and said, look, this is when it was really tragic,
他在所有这些方面都很棒，他在这方面太惊人了，是最棒的人之一，但他也有自己的专属领域，你知道的，因为我合作最多的人其实是马丁·斯科塞斯（Scorsese），因为他有电影基金会。他从70年代、70年代末、80年代初开始，就拜访了镇上的每一家电影厂，并说，听着，这是在真正悲剧的时候，
when the products they had made since their existence were really fading away and dying and weren't being taken care of. This is just on the cusp of VHS coming around in home entertainment. So he was really out there at the very beginning with the Film Foundation saying, this is the biggest cultural historical thing
当他们自成立以来制作的产品真正开始褪色、消亡且无人照料时。这恰好在VHS（录像带）出现和家庭娱乐兴起的前夕。所以他真的是在最开始就和电影基金会一起出面说，这是这个国家所能提供的最大的文化历史事物，
that this country has to offer and we have to preserve it and we have to take care of it. We have to invest money and time and manpower into figuring this out. So being a part of his Film Foundation has been, I mean, one of the great honors in my life. It's great. We'll be right back.
我们必须保护它，我们必须照顾它。我们必须投入金钱、时间和人力来搞清楚这一点。所以作为他的电影基金会的一部分，这意味着——我生命中最大的荣誉之一。太棒了。我们马上回来。
All right, back to the show. Paul, I know you're a huge, you're a big comedy fan and you've obviously collaborated with Sandler. And married the funniest woman in Hollywood. Yeah. Or in the world. Or Tracy. Maya Rudolph Tracy.
好的，欢迎回到节目。保罗，我知道你是个超级迷，你是个狂热的喜剧迷，而且你显然和桑德勒合作过。还娶了荷里活最搞笑的女人。对。或者说世界上最搞笑的。或者说特雷西。玛雅·鲁道夫·特雷西。
Maya was one of our first guests. I said that to her. I said, you were one of the first guests? She was like, no, I was. I said, I think you were. She was like one of the first two or three, right? Yeah. Maya is one of those people, as you know.
玛雅是我们的第一批嘉宾之一。我对她说过。我对她说，你是第一批嘉宾吗？她当时就说，不，我是。我说，我想是的。她说，大概是前两三个之一吧？对。玛雅就是那种人，如你所知。
Did you give her a piece of the pie? No, no. We should have. We sent her a cake though. Yeah. But she is one of those people that anytime you're doing anything funny, you go, so then it would be great.
你给她分一杯羹了吗？不，不。我们本该给的。不过我们给她寄了个蛋糕。对。但她就是那种人，无论你在做什么有趣的事，你都会觉得，哦，那如果能有玛雅加入就好了。
And then God, if we could get Maya. Just to stamp it. Yeah, you know, because she's so... How did you guys meet? Where did that, as Will was saying, you've been a huge fan of comedy for a long time. Was it just, did you just fan out on her and say, will you have dinner with me?
然后天哪，如果我们能请到玛雅。那就稳了。对，你知道的，因为她太——你们是怎么认识的？那是怎么——正如威尔所说，你长期以来一直是个狂热的喜剧迷。是不是，你只是对她顶礼膜拜，然后说，“愿意和我吃晚饭吗”？
It was just like that. Yeah. It's simple. Or did you swipe left or right? How does, I don't know how it works. See, Paul? It's not easy, is it? It's not easy to bite your tongue with Bateman.
差不多就是那样。对。很简单。还是说你向左划还是向右划？这怎么——我不知道它是怎么运作的。看，保罗？这不容易，对吧？在贝特曼面前管住自己的嘴可真不容易。
He wants to hurt me. I know. You know, it's funny. I'm not sure what it is. I guess it's like anything like, you know, I don't know, there's actors that wanted to be rock stars or musicians wanted to be actors. Like people that making serious films,
他想伤害我。我知道。你知道，这很有趣。我不太确定那是什么。我猜这就跟任何事情一样，你知道，我不知道，有些演员想当摇滚巨星，或者音乐人想当演员。就像那些拍严肃电影的人，
really just like the one thing they really love was comedies. Right. I had made these films. I thought that they were funny, but people were saying like lean areas. You make really funny shit. Well, I think you never ask for a laugh
其实他们真正唯一热爱的东西就是喜剧。没错。我拍过这些电影。我觉得它们很好笑，但人们会说，导演，你拍的喜剧他妈的真搞笑。好吧，我觉得你从不刻意索取笑声，
and that's what makes it so goddamn funny. There's no winking. It's great. Sorry, go ahead. Thank you. Yeah, because everything that I watched or in my daily kind of existence was just like, I just devoured that stuff.
而这正是它如此该死的好笑的原因。里面没有任何挤眉弄眼。太棒了。抱歉，你继续。谢谢。对，因为我观看的一切，或者在我日常的生活中，就是——我只是如饥似渴地吞噬那些东西。
And I met Maya when she'd started SNL. What was that meaning? How'd you guys meet? Well, you know, the funny thing is is that... Does she make you laugh at home too, Paul? She sure makes us laugh. She just must be a cut up at home. Somebody once said to me, that reminds me,
我是在玛雅刚开始做《周六夜现场》（SNL）的时候认识她的。那次见面是怎样的？你们是怎么认识的？嗯，你知道，有趣的是……她在家里也让你笑吗，保罗？她确实让我们笑。她在家里肯定是个开心果。曾经有人对我说过，
I think I told this once, somebody said to me years ago, when Amy and I were married, they said, what's it like being married to the funniest person in America? And I said, you'd have to ask my wife. What? Do you find that funny people
这让我想起，我想我以前说过一次，多年前埃米（Amy）和我结婚时，有人问我：“娶了全美最搞笑的人是什么感觉？”我说：“你得去问我妻子。”什么？你觉得搞笑的人
are generally pretty serious when they're at home? Yes. Uh-huh. Nothing funny about it. But I want to know that. How did you meet Paul? How did you and Miami? I really do.
在家里通常也挺严肃的吗？是的。嗯哼。一点也不搞笑。但我很想知道。保罗，你们是怎么认识的？你和玛雅是怎么认识的？我真的很想知道。在《周六夜现场》，对吧？在《周六夜现场》。当时里面有威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）和莫莉·香农（Molly Shannon）。我当时认识了莫莉·香农，她说，你知道的，你可以来看看我们是怎么做这档节目的。当时我正在写《逗爱锤击》（Punch-Drunk Love），我迷上了桑德勒以前在那里的那段时光。所以我接受了那个邀请，
At SNL, right? At SNL. That was at the time with Will Ferrell and Molly Shannon. And I had met Molly Shannon and she said, you know, you could come and you can see how we do this. And at the time I was writing Punch Drunk Love and I was obsessed with that time that Sandler had been there. So I accepted that offer to come
去参观并在幕后观看。然后莫莉说，好吧，你知道的，你可以导演一个短片。于是我导演了一部她参演的短片，得以亲眼见证这整个节目的内部运作。当时我也正在结识桑德勒，向他打听他在那里的经历。我正准备和他一起拍《逗爱锤击》。
and look and then watch behind the scenes. And then Molly said, well, you know, you can direct a short. So I directed a short with her in it and just got to kind of witness the inner workings of this whole thing. And at that time I was also getting to know Sandler and asking him about his time there. I was getting ready to make Punch Drunk Love with him.
就在我在那里待了一周准备离开时，我的脑袋转个不停。我想，嗯，那很棒，但我他妈的再也不想这么干了，因为工作强度太大了。那是完全不同的工作节奏，我很高兴自己经历过，但有这么一次体验就够了。他们说有人把一张纸塞到我手里或者类似的东西。
And as I was getting ready to leave after my week there, my head was spinning. I was like, well, that was great, but I don't want to fucking do that again because it was so much. It was a different pace of work and I was thrilled to have done it, but that was enough of a taste. They said there was a piece of paper that somebody had put in my hands or something like that.
我看了看，上面的信息显示下周将有一位新演员加入。她的名字叫玛雅·鲁道夫。我至今还记得在纸上看到她的名字的那一刻。你可能也有过这种感觉，当你第一次看到某个东西时，你意识到我的生活刚刚发生了改变。我不知道是怎么回事。
And I looked at it and the information was on it that there was a new cast member starting next week. And her name was Maya Rudolph. And I can remember seeing her name on that piece of paper. You've had any feeling like this, but you see something for the first time and you realize that my life has just changed. I don't know how.
我不知道为什么。我不知道刚刚发生了什么。所以……哇。但你很快就会继续生活。不管你有什么别的事要做，你都得继续。但回想起来，显然那种冲动、那种闪闪发光的感觉——
I don't know why. I don't know what just happened. And so... Wow. But quickly you kind of move on. Whatever you have something else to do, you have to eat it. But looking back, obviously that impulse, that kind of shining kind of feeling
任何如果我们对此保持开放心态的人都可能会经历的感觉——确实发生了。所以我四处闲逛，然后在电视上看到了她，看到了她在做什么。我和节目组的一些人保持着联系，我想，天哪，这个女人太棒了。在我回去的路上，我顺道去看了一场，我们在节目现场相遇了，然后我不得不去伦敦筹备《逗爱锤击》。
that can happen to any of us if we're open to it happened. And so I roamed around and then I saw her on television and I saw what she was doing. And I stayed in touch with a few people from the show and I was like, my God, this woman's amazing. And on my way back through, I stopped to watch and we met at the show and then I had to go on to London to work on Punch Drunk Love.
接着我到了伦敦，我说，嗯，有些事情感觉不对劲。于是我又回到了纽约。哇。我回去了，然后……这他妈太美妙了，老兄。所以你回纽约是因为你觉得自己被她吸引了，然后给她打电话说，我们出去吧？对。
And then I got to London and I said, well, something didn't feel right. And I just came back to New York. Wow. And I came back and then... That's fucking beautiful, man. So you come back to New York because you felt drawn back to her and called her and said, let's go out? Yeah.
不，我太喜欢这个了。我本来很想在里面开个玩笑的，但我太喜欢这个故事了。他简直是在动摇我冷酷的心。肖恩也有那种感觉，当有人把一张宣传新“万斯”（Vons）超市开业的传单塞给他时，他也看到了那个新开在转角处的超市，从而有了那种看到某个东西的感觉。哦，我还以为你是说他开车路过一家新的“真真”（Chin Chin）中餐厅，
No, I love that. I wanted to make a joke in there so badly, but I love that story. He just altered my cold heart. Sean had that feeling, that same feeling of seeing something written when somebody pushed a flyer for a new Vons that was opening around the corner for her. Well, I thought you were saying when he drove by a new Chin Chin
然后不得不掉头……他知道他的人生已经——我不得不掉头，而且从此就再也没有离开过。杰森发现“荷里活报道/Deadline Hollywood”出了一个应用程序时，也有同感。但那他妈的太不可思议了，老兄。我太喜欢了。玛雅也让我想起了这一点，保罗，你和我是同一天、同一年出生的。每年她都会提醒我。
and he had to double back and... He knew his life was... I've had to turn back and I haven't left since. Jason felt the same way when he found out that Deadline Hollywood had an app. But that's fucking incredible, man. I love that. Maya reminds me too, Paul, that you and I born the same day, same year. Every year, she reminds me.
哦，哇。我无时无刻不在想这件事。我们是一类人，肖恩。6月26日。你们是吗？1970年6月26日。你们两个家伙是……
Oh, wow. I think of it all the time. We're one and the same, Sean. June 26. Are you guys? June 26, 1970. June 27, 1970. You two guys are.
对。但你们是在哪个城市出生的？芝加哥。长青公园。我出生在长青公园的一家医院里，但我通常就直接说芝加哥。对。哇。
Yeah. But what city were you born in? Chicago. Evergreen Park. I was born in the hospital in Evergreen Park, but I just say Chicago. Yeah. Wow.
你呢？我出生在洛杉矶这里，也就是现在的科学教中心，以前好像叫圣约翰医院。哦，哇。不，那是黎巴嫩山Cedars of Lebanon。在富兰克林街？或者不，不，再往东一点。
You? I was born here in Los Angeles at what is now the Scientology Center, which was St. John's, I guess it was. Oh, wow. No, it was Cedars of Lebanon. It was called Cedars of Lebanon. On Franklin? Or no, no, the far east of there.
就在日落大道和荷里活大道交汇的地方，那栋蓝色的大楼。差不多靠近普罗斯特街。对，就在拐角处。那栋楼是从天主教变成科学教的吗？没，就是那样。太神奇了。嘿，你知道，你提到了桑德勒。你很早就从亚当身上看到了什么别人没有看到的东西？
Right there where Sunset and Hollywood meet, that big blue building. Almost near Prospect. Yeah, right around the corner. It went from Catholic to Scientology, that building? That's right. That's amazing. Hey, you know, you mentioned Sandler. What was it you saw in Adam earlier than anybody else did?
嗯，我一直很喜欢亚当生气的时候，你知道，他暴力的一面会爆发出来。我觉得我看到的故事——我记得有个小品叫《丹尼斯秀》（The Denise Show），他在里面和他的前女友丹尼斯说话，丹尼斯由香农·达里蒂（Shannon Darity）扮演，这个前提已经够有趣的了，他一直试图把她追回来。但有一个时刻，他开始尖叫。我想是他爸爸打电话来并用了免提，他开始对他爸爸尖叫。那一刻，桑德勒，他太投入了，以至于他眼白
Well, I always liked it when Adam would get angry, you know, the violent part of him would come out. And it was like, and I guess I saw the story that I remember, there was a sketch called the Denise Show where he's talking to his ex-girlfriend Denise, who's played by Shannon Darity, and it's a funny enough premise, and he keeps trying to woo her back. But there's a moment when he starts screaming. I think his dad calls up and is on the speakerphone, and he starts screaming at his father. And there was a moment where Sandler, he's so invested in it that the whites of his
都变成了黑色，我能感觉到——那种愤怒的程度以及对这个表演的投入。我说，这真是不同寻常，他不仅仅是在尖叫或表现得像那样，在这一切的背后，他可能完全是个精神病患者。我太喜欢了。太棒了。我太喜欢了。是的，而且你知道，他在肢体语言上非常有办法，而且我，是的，非常喜欢和亚当合作。
eyes turn black, and I could just, there was a level of anger and commitment to this performance. I said, that is something else, that he's not just screaming and being like, he potentially is completely psychotic underneath all of it. I loved it. That's great. I love that. Yeah, and it was, you know, he has a great physical way about him, and I, yeah, loved working with Adam.
你有没有过任何渴望——特别是现在有这么多这种迷你剧——那种想法曾经吸引过你吗？就是能够在一个更长的时间跨度里去讲述一个故事。好吧。我不知道，我在这里说话得小心点，因为就在过去几周里，我开始对一种在我看来非常不幸的转变感到有点全神贯注、甚至有些焦虑，那就是80分钟的故事被拍成像九集那样的，你知道的，东西，这似乎成了当下的潮流，就像这就是我们
Do you ever have any desire to, especially now that there makes so many of these sort of limited series, does that ever, does that ever appeal to you, the idea of being able to tell over a longer, yeah. Okay. I don't know, I want to be careful what I say here, because I've only over in the past couple of weeks have become a little bit preoccupied with the, what seems to be a real unfortunate turn of events, which is 80 minute stories being turned into like nine part, you know, things that, it just seems to be the kind of, the call of the day, like this is what
正在做的事情，然而事实上，你知道，这就好比滚开，我不需要——这被拉得太长了，你知道我的意思。我的意思是，我昨晚还在看《开罗紫玫瑰》，大概92分钟，绝对完美，这里面装了那么多的故事。你知道这太有趣了，因为人们总是那样说，他们会说，“你看过某某吗？你看过那个新剧什么什么的吗？”然后他们会说，“我试着看了，嗯，不，你得等到第九集才真正变好，第三集才开始好看，对吧。”我知道，他妈的，滚开。
we're doing, when in fact, you know, it's like piss off, I don't, this is, this is stretched out way too much, you know, I mean, I was watching the purple rose of Cairo last night, which is about 92 minutes, and absolutely perfect, and this is packed so much story. You know, it's so interesting, because people say that all the time, they're like, did you see so and so, did you see the new series blank or whatever, and they're like, I try to get it, well, no, you got to wait nine episodes in, just really good, third one, right. I know, fuck, piss off.
难道就不能从第一集开始就好吗？对。不，所以，但我只有在最近真正有这种感觉时才会这样，而且——我其实没什么底气，因为我真的没怎么看——我不想在这里听起来像个混蛋，但我真的没看太多，因为我的观影习惯总是这样：如果我有机会看电视，我他妈最后总是去看老电影，你知道的，这就像是我的重力把我拉向那个方向，利用我一天中仅有的时间。但你知道，有时你会遇到一个非常宏大的故事，比如一个宏大的
Can it be good after the first one? Yeah. No, so I, but I only have been really feeling this lately when I, and I, I don't have a little leg to stand on, because I haven't really, I don't, I don't want to sound like an asshole here, but I, I haven't seen much of it, because my viewing always goes like, if I have an opportunity to watch TV, I fucking end up, I'm watching old movies, you know, it's just sort of like my gravity pulls me that way, with the time that I have in the day, but you know, you know, sometimes you have a story that's very large, like a large
故事，任何史诗般的故事，而那些都很棒。过去曾有过这样的机会，他们会有像《战争风云》（The Winds of War）或者《根》（Roots）这样的作品，或者这些巨大的迷你剧，当时的感觉是，好吧，那太棒了，那曾经本身就是一种艺术品。但现在我感觉到这种慢动作的转向，把故事拉得太长了，我认为，我想在这背后，我有一种恐惧：那种在最好不超过两小时（最好是90分钟）内讲好一个故事的极其困难的挑战，将开始逐渐失传，因为我认为这是一种非常、非常宝贵的讲故事的工具，你知道的，那种结构
scale story, any kind of epic stories, and those are great, and there used to be this opportunity, they would have like the winds of war, or, you know, roots, or these sort of, these huge miniseries, it was like, okay, that's fantastic, that used to be a kind of work of art in and of itself. But now I feel this kind of slow motion turn towards the stories stretched out too much, I think, I guess underneath it, I have a fear that the painfully difficult challenge of telling a story in preferably under two hours, hopefully 90 minutes, will start to get lost, because I think it's a very, very valuable story telling to, you know, that structure
非常棒。是的。我不想看到这种东西失传。有一种风险，就是我们正在重新训练我们欣赏这些事物的方式。我看了那个——内维尔·张伯伦（Neville Chamberlain）的故事，你知道的，他和希特勒签署慕尼黑协定以割让苏台德区等等等等，试图避免战争。我那天晚上看这个只是为了放松一下。只是为了放松？
is great. Yeah. I don't want to see that get lost. There is the, the, the risk that we rewiring how we appreciate those things, and I watched that, the story of a Neville Chamberlain, you know, signing the Munich agreement with Hitler over the Sudetenland, et cetera, et cetera, trying to avoid war. This was just to unwind the other night. Just to unwind?
对。有趣的是，他们讲述的是一个非常简单的故事，这只是那个时代的一个快照，是一个非常具体的历史切片，以及这两个试图改变……的人。我在看到一半时突然意识到——顺便回应你刚才的观点——我当时想，我很惊讶他们居然没有试图把它拉长，而且他们居然真的拍了这样一部电影，这在我观看的时候让我感到相当惊讶，因为我们已经变得太习惯于、我们的脑回路已经被训练成了——太好了，现在这会有12集了。
Yeah. And what was interesting was, was they were telling this really simple story that was just a snapshot of that time, and of that very specific story, and these two guys who tried to alter the course of, and I realized halfway through, I thought, to your point, I, I was like, I'm surprised that they didn't try to stretch it out, and that they'd actually made this film, became quite surprising to me while I was watching it, because we've become so accustomed to, and our brains are wired to, you know, great, there's going to be 12 episodes of this now.
对。是的。我们来聊聊相反的东西：预告片。我想你一定很喜欢预告片，从你的预告片有多棒来看，而且我想你是自己剪的？我喜欢预告片。预告片本身就是一种小型艺术形式，我过去曾经自己剪过，或者和别人合作过。
Right. Yeah. Let's talk about the opposite, trailers. I think you love trailers based on how incredible your trailers are, and I think you cut them yourself? I love trailers. Trailers are their own little art form, and I have cut them in the past or collaborated with people.
我们做的最后一个预告片不是我剪的，是由一个叫乔尔（Joel）的家伙剪的，他有一家叫“纵横比”（Aspect Ratio）的公司。那是一个美妙的时刻，我把电影交给他，然后说：“你能做点什么吗？”结果它立刻就完美得不得了，我们什么都没说。我们只说：“就是这样。”你知道，真的很棒。真的吗？哇。
The last one that we did was, was not cut by, by me, it was cut by a guy named Joel, who's got a company called Aspect Ratio, and it was one of those great moments where I just handed the film over and said, can you do something, and it was so perfect right away that we didn't say anything. We just said, that's it. You know, it was great. Really? Wow.
那种感觉真的很有趣，但是的，我总是——对我来说，去电影院坐着的一大乐趣就在于此。我想世界上大概有两种人，一种是喜欢坐下来看预告片的人，另一种是喜欢看电影职员表（字幕）的人，你知道的，喜欢看字幕的人，以及不喜欢看字幕的人，我喜欢看字幕。我也喜欢。对。
And that was a really fun feeling, but yeah, I always, that was one of the joys to me of going to sit in a movie theater. I guess there's people, there's probably two types of people in the world, people that like to sit down and watch trailers, and then people that like to watch the credits of movies, you know, people that like to watch the credits, and people that don't like to watch the credits, I like to watch the credits. I do too. Yeah.
你曾经用我认为最棒的方式描述过拥有四个孩子的感受，我想当我请玛雅来时我提到过这一点，那就是——我会把它揉合一下，你来纠正我——有四个孩子就像家里燃起了四团温暖的炉火，光是听他们在周围跑来跑去，听起来你和我一样是个居家的人。你是如何在如此高强度工作的同时，还能成为一个不只一个、两个、三个，而是四个孩子的完美父亲的？嗯，我希望如此。我的意思是，时间会证明一切。
You once described having four kids in the best way I thought possible, and I think I mentioned this when we had my on, which was, and I'll mash this up, you correct me, that having four kids is like having four cozy fires burning in the house, just hearing them run around, and it sounds like you're as much of a homebody as I am. How do you manage to work as hard as you do and still be an incredible father to not one, not two, not three, but four kids? Well I hope so. I mean, time will tell.
是的，这非常危险。我记得露西尔·鲍尔（Lucille Ball）在60年代中期做过那些很棒的电台采访。对。我不知道你们有没有听过。它们在天狼星卫星广播（Sirius XM）上播过一阵子，你听到所有这些人在谈论他们作为父母的优势，然后你就会意识到，时间确实证明了完全不同的结果——有这些人在谈论，你知道的，我们真的很花时间在
Yeah, this is very dangerous. I remember there's these great episodes with Lucille Ball doing these radio interviews from the mid-60s. Yeah. I don't know if you've heard those. They were on Serious XM for a little while, and you hear all these people talking about their strengths as parents, and then you sort of realize that time has really proven quite differently that there are these people talking about, you know, we really spend time on the
周末陪伴孩子以及其他所有事情，然后你会想，嗯哼，嗯哼，请继续关注这本书。我不知道。写作的好处之一，我想，就是能够在家工作，能够在家里陪伴家人，并且在山谷里拍电影。好吧，这也有帮助，不用跑得太远。但即便如此，我想，我不知道，当我为了拍《霓裳魅影》去伦敦时，他们确实来过一段时间，但随后他们明白，有两个月你将看不到我，你知道，但没关系，在一年12个月里，
weekends and everything else, and you're like, uh-huh, uh-huh, stay tuned for the book. I don't know. One of the benefits of writing, I suppose, is the ability to work from home, the ability to be present at home, and shooting movies about the valley. Well, that helps, too, to not go too far away. But even still, I think that, you know, I don't know, when I went to London to make Phantom Thread, they did come for some of the time, but then they understood that for two months you're not going to see me, you know, but that's okay, out of 12 months in
只要我在其他时间都和你在一起，你就不会太想念我。对，抱歉，杰森，当他说“陪伴（be present）”时，意思是你在哪里，你就专注于哪里，并且你意识到周围的环境和周围其他人，等等。明白了。不仅仅是人在心不在。好的，很好。对。没错。
a year, as long as I'm with you the other chunk of time, you won't miss me that much. Yeah, sorry, Jason, when he says be present, it means that you are where you are and that you're aware of the surroundings and of other people, et cetera. Got it. Not just being filled in. Okay, good. Yeah. Right.
明白了。我得说，我真的很喜欢——虽然这么说有点陈词滥调——你对洛杉矶的热爱，以及你通过如此多不同的方式、在如此多不同的时代讲述洛杉矶故事的倾向，我觉得这真的非常迷人。你讲述加州经历的方式，是其他任何人都没有的。因为我认为一直有一种偏见，觉得加州因为比较新所以没那么有趣，觉得它不如东海岸，它总是以这种方式被看低，但你讲述的故事却展现了它实际上是多么丰富，只是风格不同而已。
Understood. I will say, I do love, and this is almost trite to say, but your affinity for your love of telling stories about Los Angeles in so many different ways and so many different times, I find it really fascinating. You tell stories about the experience of California, unlike anybody else. Because I think that there's always been that rub that California is not as interesting because it's newer, that it's not the East Coast, that it's always kind of looked down on in this way, but you tell these stories about actually how rich it is, it's just different.
而且他们有道奇队（Dodgers），对吧，保罗？是的，他们有。你知道吗？好吧，是的，他们有。你是道奇队的球迷吗？对，我赶上了。得了吧。当然。
And they've got the Dodgers, right, Paul? Yes, they do. You know? Well, yes, they do. Are you a Dodger guy? Yeah, I catch a map. Come on. Of course.
嘿，所以昆汀说，任何伟大的电影人一生中只能拍10部电影，你已经拍了9部了。告诉我这不是真的。哦，那是鬼扯。我不知道。我不明白他在胡扯些什么。好吧，太棒了。这就好像是，我不能。因为我需要你拍的不止最后一部。
Hey, so Tarantino says, any great filmmaker only has 10 films in them, you've made nine. Tell me that's not true. Oh, that's horseshit. I don't know. I don't understand what he's on about that. Okay, great. It's just like, I can't. Because I need more than one more from you.
对。你一定会的。我的意思是，我不知道。你会像克林特·伊斯特伍德（Clint Eastwood）那样一直拍到他们把你抬走吗？是的。我不知道。你必须这样。这是一个肯定的回答。
Yeah. You got it. I mean, I don't know. Are you going to do it like Clint Eastwood until they cart you off? Yes. I don't know. You have to. That's a yes.
你还能做什么呢？没错。我想，是的，你还能做什么呢？你必须这样。因为我猜随着你年龄的增长，你看待事物的视角会发生变化。换句话说，你今天拍《卡罗来纳》或者《赌场风云》（硬八）的方式会和当时不同，不是更好，也不是更坏，只是不同。你没有拍过一部烂片。
What else are you going to do? Exactly. I think, yeah, what else are you going to do? You have to. Because I would imagine your perspective on stuff changes as you get older. In other words, you would have made hard eight differently today than you did then, no better, no worse, just differently. You haven't made one bad film.
对。我想看看你85岁时的脑子是什么样的，什么对你来说是有趣的，你是如何构图的等等。所以请不要停下来，好吗？好吧，谢谢。继续拍下去。谢谢你这么说。谢谢你拍出真正好玩、好电影，保罗。
Yeah. I want to see what your brain is like when you're 85, what's interesting to you and how you compose shots and all that stuff. So don't stop, please. Well, thank you. Keep going. Thank you for saying that. Thanks for making really good shit, Paul.
是啊。我想看看你85岁的时候大脑会是什么样，什么对你来说是有趣的，你又是如何构图的等等。所以请不要停下来。嗯，谢谢你。继续加油。谢谢你这么说。谢谢你做出这么棒的作品，保罗。
Yeah, Paul. Paul, you're batting average. You're one of the fucking greats, man. I always tell you that when I see you in person because I can't, there's no other, I can't dress it up. I just can't dress it up, man. You really honored us with hanging out for an hour, Paul. Thank you, Paul.
是的，保罗。保罗，你的安打率太高了。你绝对是史上最伟大的传奇之一，老兄。我每次见到你本人都会这么对你直说，因为我没法委婉，我真的没办法委婉，老兄。你能花一个小时和我们闲聊，真的太给面子了，保罗。谢谢你，保罗。
Thank you, buddy. Thank you very much. Are you kidding? Thank you guys, really. Please say hi to Maya. I sure will. I sure will. I hope I see you guys in person for real soon.
谢谢你，兄弟。非常感谢。开什么玩笑？谢谢你们，真的。请代我向玛雅问好。我一定会的。我一定会的。希望我们很快能在线下真正见一面。
I hope I can come see your Oscar Levant play, Sean. I really genuinely am. I love Oscar Levant. I would love for you to. Are you playing? Who's playing Oscar Levant? That would be me. You're playing Oscar Levant?
希望我能去看你演的奥斯卡·黎凡特戏剧，肖恩。我是真心实意这么想的。我太喜欢奥斯卡·黎凡特了。我真的很想去看。你在演吗？谁在演奥斯卡·黎凡特？那个人就是我。你在演奥斯卡·黎凡特？
I'm playing Oscar Levant, yeah. You should hear him play Rhapsody in blue, too, on piano. He's a classically trained pianist. It's insane. Paul, thank you for being here. We love you. We love everything about you. Thanks so much, Paul.
我在演奥斯卡·黎凡特，对。你还应该听听他在钢琴上弹奏的《蓝色狂想曲》。他是受过古典音乐训练的钢琴家。这太疯狂了。保罗，谢谢你来到这里。我们爱你。我们爱你的一切。非常感谢，保罗。
Are you kidding? Thanks, guys. Hopefully we'll see you out at the stadium if baseball gets our act together. Look, fingers crossed, they will, they will. All right. Have a great day, man. See you, man. All right.
开什么玩笑？谢谢你们，伙计们。希望如果棒球赛事恢复的话，能在球场见到你们。听着，祈祷吧，他们会恢复的，会的。好吧。祝你有美好的一天，老兄。再见，老兄。好吧。
See you. Bye, buddy. Bye, Paul. That was a good get, Jay. I love you. Jay, oh my God. I mean, I've been working this for a couple of weeks with you guys saying, I booked somebody that I'm excited about.
再见。再见，兄弟。再见，保罗。这次采访请得真不错，杰。我爱你。杰，哦天哪。我是说，我为了这事跟你们筹划了好几周，告诉你们我预约了一个让我激动不已的人。
Oh, this was the one. That you guys won't be excited about. I tried to kind of fake it a little bit. I can't believe it. I can't. You know, it's true, though. You know, when you name all his movies for Tracy, again, I know you said it at the top of this episode, but it's Boogie Nights, Magnolia, Punch, Drunk, Love.
哦，就是这个。你们绝对会兴奋不已。我刚才还假装淡定了一点点。我简直不敢相信。真的不敢。你知道的，不过这确实是真的。你知道，当你为特雷西数出他所有的电影时，我再次说过，我知道你在这一集节目开头也提过，那是《不羁夜》、《木兰花》、《微不足道的爱情》。
There will be blood. There will be blood. Likers Pizza. Likers Pizza. Now. The minister. He doesn't miss. He never misses.
还有《血色将至》。还有《血色将至》。还有《甘草披萨》。《甘草披萨》。太棒了。这位大师。他从不失手。他从未失手。
And you know, I've never misses. And there's so many years in between him making those, that you're like, oh, that's why it's so long because he invests everything that he is into these things. That's why, what you said, nine, right? He's only made nine. Yeah. Yeah. And they've all been great.
你知道，他从来没有失手过。而且他拍这些电影之间隔了那么多年，你会觉得，哦，原来耗时这么久是因为他把自己的全部都倾注到了这些作品里。这就是为什么，就像你说的，九部，对吧？他一共才拍了九部。对。对。而且每一部都非常棒。
Yeah. What a talent, that guy. I'm really, I'm just, I think I seem pretty casual all the way through that, but my goodness is that guy a hero to me. Yeah. He's amazing. Yeah. Same.
对啊。真是个天才，那家伙。我真的是，我觉得我在整个过程中表现得挺随意的，但天哪，那家伙绝对是我的偶像。对。他太棒了。对。我也是。
I know I'm just a little bit over the years from, through Maya and every time, I think that every time I'm always right on the edge at risk of embarrassing myself. And I do end up saying stuff like, your movie was incredible and I can't get over it. And then I have to walk away. That's the time I have to walk away. I really, I would, I'd love for him to make some big, broad comedy, the ones that I know he's a fan of. Yeah, I know.
我知道，这些年来通过玛雅我稍微接触过一点，而且每次，我觉得每次我都游走在让我自己感到尴尬的边缘。结果我最后还是会说出这样的话：你的电影太不可思议了，我简直无法忘怀。然后我就必须走开。那是唯一我必须走开的时候。真的，我很，我很希望他能拍一些宏大、通俗的喜剧，就是我知道他也很喜欢的那些类型。对，我知道。
The stuff that. I was going to ask him that. Yeah. I mean, I'm sure he gets that question a lot, so I'm glad none of us did because I wanted to ask him that too. But like, you know, you think about his affinity for that kind of comedy, you know, Monty Python, SNL, I bet it would just be stunning, but, um, yeah, he used to be around SNL so much, obviously.
那些东西。我本来想问他这个的。对。我是说，我确信他已经听过无数次这个问题了，所以我很高兴我们谁都没问，因为我也想问他这个。但是，你知道，你想到他对于那种喜剧的喜爱，你知道，巨蟒剧团、周六夜现场，我敢说那绝对会惊艳绝伦，但是，嗯，对啊，他以前经常在《周六夜现场》周围转悠，显而易见。
And I used to see that. You must love it. But, you know, I'd like to come, I like the conversation about, you know, the streaming versus the, the, the wide release stuff, because, you know, the wide release movies, when you go see them, you have to pay for them. But when they're at home, they kind of feel like they're free. So you don't have to buy the race to the buy from you is. So remarkable smart smart smart smart is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett
我以前也经常看到。你一定很喜欢。但是，你知道，我想谈谈，我喜欢关于流媒体与那种大规模上映电影的讨论，因为，你知道的，大规模上映的电影，你去看的时候，你得付钱。但当它们在家里播时，感觉就像是免费的。所以你不用去买……来自你的购买竞争是……如此卓越、聪明、聪明、聪明、聪明，100%有机且由本杰明手工打造的
Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjurf smart loss. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·泰利和罗伯·阿姆尤夫精心炮制的智能损失。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。